안녕하세요. 행복한 투자의 예정은
체슬리 투자자분과 함께 체슬리 모닝
브리프 오늘 6월 30월의
마지막 날 화요일 순서 시작하도록
하겠습니다. 오늘은 제가 1부
진행하고 2부를 이승준 대표께서
진행해 주시겠습니다.
아 오랜만에 왕박사를 예
>> 모닝 브리크 만났는데
>> 네
>> 중국 시장부터 보겠습니다.네 네.
어제 테크주 다시 상승하면서 상향
지수 플러스 1.2% 올라왔고요.
흥승 테크 지수는 3% 가까이
반등했습니다. 당시 거대면 3.5조
수준을 유지했어요. 업종별좀 보시면
헬스키어 필 소비자 IT 업전 검색
배웠고 바면 커뮤니케이션 에너지
부동창 업정 약세 배웠습니다. 어
저가 매수 자금 요입 그리고 글로벌
동조 화동료로 헬스케어 권용주어제
반등 나오고요. 뭐 시장 투명한 이슈
없습니다. 컨설 대안는 8% 올라하고
우바연은 요즘 8% 만성 이료는 2층
6% 올라왔어요. 소비제 관련주
어제도 반등했어요. 규모는 2증 3%
올라왔고 우리는 1% 히트리는 6%
센트 차이나 3% 올라왔습니다.
2, 3분게 에어콩 수요 확대 등
기대함으로 가정 관련주 어제도
판단했습니다. 메디 글로는 3.3%
거래 과정은 2.4% 올라왔고요.
별한 거는 반도체 정비주이잖아요. 어
또 급등했어요. 보 화는 5.8%
올라왔고요. 종미 반도체는 10%
올라왔습니다. 승미상하는 8.2%,
전선 테크는 7.3%이 3%이
대표적인 충구 대형 반도체 관련주들이
다 역사하신 것이 됐습니다. 어 2차
증지 관련주도 강세 보였고요. CT는
3%
이보 에너지는 3.8% 연공 정원은
3% 올라오고요. 한편은 소재 관련주
어제도 반등세가 나왔습니다. 자금은
3% 중국 알루미늄은 1.7% 강서
굴리는 5% 돌아왔어요. 반면는
PCB CCR 관련주세는 좀
빠졌어요. 승인테크는 매너 4% 동생
정밀는 매너 4% 호장 주시도 매너
4% 정도 하라했습니다. 어 신년물
구체 금리 여제 1.1bp
하라했습니다. 2년물 구체 금리
1.7bp 하라고 외화 환율는 염증
절성되었습니다.네
>> 그 중국 반도체 장비에서가 급등을
했는데
>> 네네
>> 우리나라 삼성전자 하이닉스의 대규모
투자 발표 있었잖아요. 네.
>> 중국 장비 업체들이 한국 업체
삼성이나 하이닉스에도
공급합니까?
>> 네. 더 뭐 다 있습니다. 예. 종미
반도 종비 공사 있잖아요. 해외적으로
나가는 물량이 있어요. 가능도 있고
삼성 전 익스까지도 커버하고
있습니다.
>> 네. 다 있습니다. 다 속서 못
나가고 있어요.
>> 그러면 한국의 업체들의 대경업 반도체
투자가 중국 장비 업체한테도 영향을
주긴 좋겠네요. 주가에
>> 그네 그 부분도 있고 일본 회사
요즘에도 케파 확대하고 있잖아요.
그러니까 다 뭐 영향을 받고
있습니다.
>> 음. 오케이.
>> 네. 음. 음 주어이 전무적으로
보시면 오통버스입니다. 오통버스는
최근에 주가는 계속 빠졌고요. 뭐
그래서 관련 리포드는 하나
찾았습니다. 어 1번기 매출에는
전에서 나오고요. 이거 동일대 매도
7.9% 감소하고 수익는 매도
12.7% 감소했습니다. GP 마진
23.6% MP 마 12.3% 정도
뭐 계속 유지했어요. 해외 매출 비중
화때에 따라서 GP 마진이 계속
개선되고 있습니다. 이번에 컨센서스
기준으로는 매출에는 동일비 14.8%
8%는 증가하고요.이는
그냥 어 마이너스에서 플러스 전환됐고
수익는 동의. 벗었는데 정도 증가
가능성이 있습니다. [콧방귀] 어
최근에 주가는 계속 빠지는 이유가
이쁜게이 실적 실적에 대한 우여감
함정이 있어서 조가는 빠졌고 어 다만
그 다음 달 7월 2일부터 5일까지
요월 달 그 버스 판매 발표할
예정이고요. 그리고 하반기는 버스
2구 환신 강화 여부에도 주무할
필요가 또 있습니다. 월 데이터
기준으로 하면은 버스 데이터는 뭐
좋게 나오고요. 버스 패밀리어는 동의
증가하고 대현버스 패밀리어는
동의.1% 1% 정도 장가였어요.
그래서 그월 달 데이터는 이보다는
좋게 나오면은 주가 아마 좀 반등
나올 수 가능성이 있긴 있습니다.
[콧방귀] 어 화연 정권 리포트
보면은 중국 군해 시장 경정력 화대
그리고 해외 진투 화대에 따라서 매수
의견을 유지했어요. 올래 내년 내년
수익는 각하가 이전 대비 11%
22% 정도 상향 조정했습니다.이
>> 홀는 원가 거 배당 중이잖아요. 배당
성형은 정량 마켓주는 99% 정도
배당했습니다.
>> 네. 시가 배당률이 한 5% 넘지
않았나?
>> 그때는 6% 정도 넘어갔어요. 네.
>> 그래서이 배당 95%을 가정하면
원래는 주당은 3 외 정도가 나올 수
있고요. 그래서 이에 썸 배당
수익률은 12% 수준까지 올라왔어요.
>> 11.6%네
>> 11.6% 6% 거의 12%
>> 시가 배당률이네
>> 오늘 예상 배당 소년입니다.
>> 원래
>> 어 뭐 타게는이 회사가
>> 뭐 과거 제가 외에 차트 좀
가져왔어요. 과거 보면은
>> 최하은 그냥 12배 수입니다.
>> 그렇네.
>> 상당까지 빠졌네 지금. 맞아요. 근데
그 EPS는 계속 성향 조정하고
있습니다.
>> 음.
>> 약간 소외되고 있는 회사로 보이고요.
>> 그리고 지금 시가 배당 수익률은 거의
역사 취거 출전까지 올라왔습니다.
>> 그래서 여기서 저도 그 탁로 내년은
12배 PR 적용하면 TP는 45
정도 나올 수 있어요.
>> 어제 종가 대비 54% 나올 수
있어요.
>> 지금 20위원대예요.
>> 네. 어
>> 28입니다.
>> 그러니까 PR 밴드 하단이
9.7배인데
지금 밴드 하단 같이 빠졌고 그죠?
>> 네. 오른쪽 PBR를 보면 22년
저점 보다는 위에 있긴 한데
>> 네
>> 근데 시가 배당률이 뭐 12% 나오면
>> 무조건 사야 될 것 같은데
>> 맞아요. 저도이 회사는 좀 계속 보고
있는데 요즘에 반도체 때문에 이런
회사는 다 계속 빠지고 있어요. 이유
없이 다만 그 2번기 실적도 나오고
3분기 그 뭐 중부 2구 관심 증세
한 번 더 확인하고 4분기 그때는
이제 뭐 공교적로 매수해도 근처지
않을까 싶어요.
>> 네.
자, 지금 방송을 보고 계신 우리
최민턴 분들 야, 우통버스 여러 번
들으셨을 건데 나도 이런 주식 사
놓고 저 12% 정도의 배당을 그것도
위하로 최근에 원화 대비 위한화가
강세가 계속 이어지고
>> 있으니까네도
사 놓고 싶다 이런 생각 드실 건데
>> 그 아라스 펀드가 7월 23일 아마
출시될 수도 있습니다. 네. 지금
마지막 작업 중인데 7월 23일 날
출시가 되면 한국, 중국, 미국,
한국, 미국 40, 40, 중국 20
요런 식으로
자산 배분을 해서 아마 들어갈 건데
그러면 만약에 아라스 펀드에서
살지 말지는 오늘 얘기하면 안 되고
>> 곧 출시가 되니까 그 일정이 확정이
되면 다시 한번 안내해 드리도록
자, 후통 버스.
>> 네.
>> 우리나라에도 지금 수익 되고 있나요?
>> 네. 다 있습니다. 비하디도 있고이
우통 버우스도 있고
>> 우통버스도 있고 그죠?
>> 겠습니다.
>> 네.
>> 우통 버스는 전기차 버스만 하는 건
아니죠.
>> 어, 지금 그 전통 에너시 그 뭐
디저에서 그 전기자로 좀 바보고
있습니다.
>> 전기 버스 훨씬 더 비싸요. 네.
얼마 전에 한 2주 됐던 거 같은데
기아자동차 자동차에서 이제 버스 생산
중단하겠다. 아
>> 그게 이유가 결국은 이제 중국
업체하고 경쟁에 있어서 생산성 마진이
안 나다 보니까
기다 들었는데
통버스 글로벌 중국 시장에서 1등이면
글로벌 1등 아니에요.
>> 네. 글로벌 1등이
>> 글로벌 마켓 10% 1등입니다.
>> 맞습니다.
>> 알겠습니다.
>> 네.
자, 종국 시장 받고 그다음에 어
미국 시장 유리프로께서 소개해 주시
주시겠습니다. 어제
>> 다 반등했어요. 그죠?
>> 다 시작할 때는 되게 많이
받았었는데요. 결국 반등하면서
끝났고요.
>> 네. 그래서 어제 월요일 정말 미국장
말씀드리도록 하겠습니다. 그래서 말씀
주셨듯이 큰 틀에서 보면은 이제
반등인 건 맞았거든요. 장초반에 좀
뭐 한 8% 10% 이렇게게 빠지면서
편하진 않았는데 결국 반등하면서 역시
뭐 A 인프라 투자에 대해 시장의
신뢰가 아직 남아 있다라는 이제
신호를 신고가 통해서도 좀 보여줬던
장이었습니다. 지수들부터 먼저
보시면은 좀 모두 상승한 가운데 SP
어제 1.2% 올랐고요. 나스닥도
제가 2% 가량 올랐지만 좀 오버레일
기준으로 보시면은 지난주에 하락분을
아직 다 상대한 상태는 아니다라는 점
한번 짚어 드리고자 합니다. 그리고
필반 지수도 보시면 어제한 3.8%
정도 상승하긴 했는데 역시 이제
오버리를 기준해서 또 역산을 해
보면은 어제 반등 전까지는 한 10%
정도 이미 빠진 상태이거든요. 그래서
지수 수치 자체로만 보시면 어제 장이
좀 본질은 신고가 이제 뭐 랠리가
다시 급하게 붙었다라기보다는 이제
지난주에 좀 조정이 좀 있었던 이후에
낙폭 과대 구간에서 좀 저가 매수세가
다시 들어온 회복장의 성격이
강했다라고 보실 수 있을 것
같습니다. 자 하루 변동폭만 기도
그동안에 좀 말씀드렸었는데 오거래일
좀 먼저 말씀드린 이유는 오늘
아무래도 상반기 마지막 거래일 앞도
이제 끝난 미국장인만큼 좀 변곡점이
될 수도 있어서 흐름 짚어드리고자
함이었고요. 그래서 이제 뒤에 좀
짚어 드릴 텐데 뭐 오늘 그리고
어제가 월말, 본기말 그리고 상반기
좀 수급이 겹친 장이었다라는 점 함께
참고해 주실 필요 있을 것 같습니다.
그래서 이제 더더욱 어제 반등에서 좀
단기적인 리밸런싱 수급하고 장기적인
시장 방향을 좀 구분해서 봐야
된다라는 좀 지수 통해서 먼저 말씀을
드렸고요. 어 이동하셔서 우측의 금리
쪽 보시면은 이제 미국 10년물
금리가 4.37% 부근에서 뭐 그렇게
큰 변화는 없었습니다. 유가도 아래쪽
유동에서 보시면은 70%대로 조금
속고 올라오긴 했습니다. 그래서
인플레이션 부담 좀 남아 있긴 하지만
장기 금리가 크게 튀지는 않았기
때문에 전반적으로 성장주가
반등하기에도 우호적인 환경이었다라고
보실 수 있을 것 같습니다. 이제
특별히 어제 이제 리사쿠 관련해서 좀
대법원 판결이 있었는데요. 하단에
이제 텍스트 쪽에 간단히 기재를 해
드렸는데 리사쿠 관련해서 대부분
판결이 금리 좀 안정에 일부
긍정적으로 작용한 모양세가
있었습니다. 리사국이 누구냐 하면은
이제 패드 연준의 이사인데요. 이제
기준 금리 결정에 참여하는
인물입니다. 그래서 뭐 사실 뭐
연준의 독립성 논란 자체가 뭐 새로
나온 이슈는 아니기는 하고 전
이장이었던 이제 제론파월 때도 이제
뭐 트럼프가 공개적으로 금리 인하를
압박하기도 했었고 뭐 해임하겠다 이런
언론도 그 거론도 있긴 했었는데 다만
이번에 이제 리사 국권이 조금 더
중요했던 이유는 뭐 단순한 발언이나
압박을 하겠다라기보다는 실제로 이제
현직인 패드 이사를 뭐 해임하려 한
사건이었기 때문에 좀 중요하다라고 볼
수 있을 것 같고 이제이 사건이 왜
있어 언제부터 있었냐 하면은 작년
8월에 트럼프 부가 이제 주택 담보
대출 관련 뭐 허위 신고 의욕을
근거로 쿡 이사 해임을 시도하려고
했었다고 합니다. 그래서 만약에
이번에 실제로 해 뭐 직무 유 그
직무를 이제 해지를 했었으면은
대통령이 뭐 페드 이사를 정치적
이유로 이제 쉽게 헤임할 수 있다라고
이제 시장에 받아들이면 금리 결정이나
물가나 고용 같은 경제 데이터보다 좀
정치권의 단기 경기 요구 좀 흔들릴
수 있는 우려가 커지기 때문에 이번
판결을 통해서 연준 독립성에 대한 뭐
우려를 완화했고 그래서 장기 금리
완화에도 좀 상대적으로 우호적인
환경이 조성됐다라고 보실 수
있겠습니다. 환율 쪽도 그간 안 짚어
드리긴 했었는데 이번 같이 보시면
달러 인덱스 소폭 하락했습니다. 달러
인덱스 달러가 이제 뭐 유론 라인이나
뭐 기타 통화 대비해서 얼마나 이제
강한지를 보는 지표인데 이제 어제
주식 시장 좀 반등하면서 안전 자산이
달러 수요가 좀 줄기도 했고 뭐 이것
때문에 또 약했다라고 볼 수도
있겠지만 좀 더 이제 눈에 띄는 거는
기재해 드리진 않았지만 엔화였는데요.
이제 블룸버그 헤드라인을 좀
나왔었는데 이제 에너가 이제 달러당
161엔 후반까지 이제 밀리면서
1986년 이후로 이제 가장 약한
수준까지 내려왔다라고 합니다. 뭐
에나 약세 자체가 뭐 증시에 미국
증시에 나쁜 환경은 아니고 오히려
뭐캐리 트레이더가 유지되기 쉽다라는
점에서는 좀 오자산에 아 위험 자산이
좀 우호적으로 비춰질 수는 있겠는데
이제 다만 문제는요 161이라는
레벨일 것 같습니다. 이제 달러당
160에 넘어선 구간은 좀 과거에도
일본 이제 정부가 환율관이었다고
하더라고요. 그래서이 160변을
넘어선 지금 구간에서는 정부의 개입
가능성에 대해서도 좀 계속 주시할
필요가 있기 때문에 트래킹할 필요가
있을 것 같습니다. 다시 위쪽으로 좀
이동하셔서 섹터 쪽 흐름 보시면은
이제 어제는 자유소비제랑 커뮤니케이션
섹터가 좀 강했습니다. 자유소비제
같은 경우에는 좀 시총이 큰 아마존
그리고 테슬라가 좀 끌고 가는
양세였고 커뮤니케이션은 이제 구글하고
메타가 좀 끌고 가는 그림이었습니다.
다만 뭐 소비주 뭐 소비 전체가 막
도와졌다라기보다는
빅테크랑 이제 플랫폼 기업 중심의
반등이 반등이었는데요. 이제 중간보
좀 빅테크 왼쪽에 이동해서 같이
보시면은 테슬라가 8.5% 4.5%
구글이 4.8% 그리고 아마존이
3.2% 오르면서 좀 강하게
올랐습니다. 근데 이제 반면에
애플이랑 마이크로소프트는 그동안 좀
올랐는데 조금 하락하면서 마무리를
했는데요. 그래서이 이런 이제 차이를
보시면 어제 장은 뭐 빅테크가 모두
같이 오른 장이었다라기보다는 좀
최근에 조정을 받았던 대형 성장적
중심으로 좀 매수세가 들어온
장이었다라고 보실 수 있겠습니다.
그또 개별 이슈가 어제 아예 없었던
건 아닙니다. 구글 같은 경우에는
이제 그 다우 지수 편입이 됐는데
기존 구성 종목이었던 베라이존을
대체를 하면서 좀 상승분에 기여를
했습니다. 그제 오거레일 짚어드리만
것t도 한번 같이 보시면 좋을 것
같아서 한번 좀 언급을 했하려고
하는데 이제 구글이 좀 연초 이후에
보시면 13% 상승하면서 가장 빅테크
쪽에서도 강하거든요. 그래서 이걸 좀
견조하다라는 의미를 좀 어 왜
그럴까를 생각해서 보시면 이제 시장이
뭐 구글을 계속 AI 케펙스이
전쟁이라고 표현을 하죠. 전쟁에서 좀
상대적으로 버틸 수 있는 플랫폼으로
보고 있다. 수치적으로만 봤을 때도
좀 생각해 볼 수 있지 않을까
싶어서요 부분 한번 특기 드리려고
했었습니다. 그리고 테슬라가 어제
8.5% 올랐던 점도 한번 짚어
드려야 될 거 같은데 특별히 뭐
기업에서 어떤 펀더멘탈적인 이슈가
있었다라기보다는 자동차 쪽 함께
보시면 우측 하단에 자동차 전기차
쪽이 [목을 가다듬음] 다 함께
올랐습니다. 루시드가 보시면 10%
가량 올랐고 리비안도 7.5% 5%
상승을 하면서 전기차 이제 종목들이
일제일 강했습니다. 뭐 수요가 당연히
뭐 하루 사이에 갑자기
좋아졌다라기보다는 성장주 반등장에서
좀 그가 많이 빠져 있었던 정의차
쪽도 같이 올랐다 정도로 짚어볼 수
있을 것 같습니다. 이제 그리고 이제
중간부로 이동하셔서 신고가 쪽
보시면은 이제 주요 지수 자체가 좀
신고가를 찍은 장은 아니긴 했는데
종목단에서 좀 52주 신고가가 뭐
IT 쪽에서 많이 나왔습니다. 특히
반도체 장비주가 좀 많이 강했는데요.
이제 보시면 KL라 테스트 장비
업플라이드리스 아니면 램리서치가 또
다시 신고가를 기록을 했습니다. 여기
이제 계속 그 벨주부전에서 말씀드렸던
코닝도 신고가에 포함이 됐고 또
헬스케어 쪽도 계속 강세 이어가고
있는데 좀 대형주인 일라이 1리 존슨
앤 존슨비 같은 대역 제약주들도 계속
신고가를 좀 기록을 했습니다. 그리고
이제 또 말씀 주셨듯이 바이오쪽
월초부터 계속 그 나스닥 바이오테크
지수가 계속 상승세를 보이고 있었기
때문에 뭐 [목을 가다듬음]
특히 바이오 쪽에서는 개별 종목
이슈도 중요하겠지만은 이제 지수 쪽
그리고 또 세고 섹터 리더십도 계속
체크할 필요 있을 것 같습니다.
왼쪽 하단에 이동하셔서 반도체 쪽
보시면은 어 대형 반도체 중에서
TSMC가 5% 넘게 오르면서 좀
가장 강했습니다. 어제는 조금 다른
반도체 흐름과 다르게 살짝 하락하긴
했었는데 TSMC가 뭐 단순히 뭐
반도체 섹터 반등뿐만이 아니라
개별적으로 좀 실적 기대가
붙었습니다. 어제 트렌드 포스
자료에서 뭔가 언급이 있었는데 2분기
총마진이 뭐 70%에 근접할 수 있고
3분기 매출도 뭐 전분기 대비해서
10% 이상 늘어날 수 있다라는
전망이 나오면서 좀 상승분에 좀
기여한 것으로 보입니다.
그리고 이제 말씀드렸던 이제
신고가적에서도 말씀드렸던 장비주가 또
강했는데요. 이제 어플라이드
머티리얼스가 10% 넘게 올랐고 램리
소치도 8.4% 4% 오르고 장비 그
테스트 단인 이제 KL도 12% 가량
상승하면서요 세 개가 이제 같이
강했다는 거는 이제 AI 투자가 이제
이어질 때 뭐 수혜를 받는
파운들이라든지 그리고 검사 체인에까지
이르게 이르기까지 다시 이제 AI
체인 전반에 매수세가 다시 회복된
점이었다라는 점에서 아직까지는요 AI
스토리의 유효성이 뭐 계속
견조하다라는 것을 수치적으로도 계속
보여주고 있는다라고 보실 수 있을 것
같습니다. 그리고 어제 샌디스크는
사실 2% 가량 하락하긴 했는데
웨스턴 디지털이라든지 시게이트 같은
그런 하드디스 하드디스크 종목들은 좀
강했거든요. 그러다 보니까 이제
메모리 전체적으로도 다시 많이 올랐던
쪽은 조정을 받았지만은 결국 이제
전반적으로 매수세나 아직 유효하다라는
쪽을 보실 수 있을 것 같습니다.
그래서 이제 랩업 한번 또 드리자면
어제 미국장 좀 장 초반에 좀
불안하긴 했었는데요. 그래도 결국
반등에 성공하면서 AI 인프라 투자에
대한 시장 실내가 아직 남아 있다라는
점을 강력하게 수치적으로 이제
보여줬고 다만 지수 기준으로는 이제
뭐 지난주라든지 계속 하락분을 완전히
되돌린 것은 아니기 때문에 이제
신고가 랠리가 뭐 재개됐다 다시 뭐
완전 리스크온이다라기보다는
낙폭 과대 이후 회복장이다라는 점을
보시는게 맞을 것 같습니다. 다만
이제 앞서 짚어드렸듯이 뭐 아직 그
상반기를 마무리하면서 수급이 좀
겹치는 구간이기 때문에 이제 기관
리밸런싱으로 단기 변동성은 커질 수
있다는 점 다시 짚어드리고요. 그리고
이제 하루하루 좀 불안정한 흐름을
시장 방향 전환으로 좀 과하게 해석할
필요는 그래도 없을 것 같다라는 점
말씀드리면서 오늘 이제 6월 30일
상반기 마지막 일인만큼 좀 오늘 다시
계장하면은 마지막 거래를 앞두고 어떤
식으로 전개가 될지 한번 살펴볼
필요가 있을 것 같습니다.
이상입니다.
>> 네. 감사합니다.
아
어제 장 시작하고는 왜 저렇게 많이
빠졌어요?
>> 어
글쎄요. 어제 갑자기 하락을 하다가
갑자기 상승을 했는데 특별한 이유는
없었던 것으로 저는 알고 있습니다.
>> 음.
어제 아무래도 그 이란하고도 미국하고
전쟁이 또 제개되는 거 아닌가 막
이런 우려감도 있었던 거 같고
마이크론이에 좀 많이 빠진 거에
대해서는 어 뭐 미국 빅테크 기업들이
중국 업체에다가
메모리를 요청할 수도 있다. 뭐
이런저런 얘기들이 막 맞물리면서
좀 초번에 좀 빠지는 그런 분위기가
연출됐던 거 같은데 좀 의미 있는
부분이 말씀하신 대로 커뮤니케이션 좀
올라오고 자유 소비제가 2.7%
올라오고 그죠.요
요 부분이 아무래도 유가도 좀 빠지고
금리도 다시 4.4m로 밑으로 좀
떨어지고
거기에
소비가 좀 회복될 수 있다라는 그
워낙 소비제가 좀 많이 빠졌으니까
>> 그래서 그래서 저 짚어드렸던 것처럼
진짜 빠졌던 종목들이 다시 오르는
장소였고 또 리밸런싱이 아무래도 방기
앞두고 있기 때문에 그런 점에서 좀
흔들렸던게 아닐까 특별한 이슈는
없었던 것으로 저는 알고 있습니다.
>> 네. 그러니까 특별한 이슈 없이 왜
이런 변화가 좀 있었을까 생각해 보면
거기에다가 지금 뭐 테슬라 같은
경우에는 이제 곧 판매수가 발발표될
건데 판매 자체는 좀 잘되고 있다라고
그러면서
소비제 중에서
소비제 중에서 테슬라가 가장 강하게
좀 반등이 들어오는 모습이고
맨디스크 이런게 좀 빠지고 마이크로
이 총 중반에 급락을 하다 보니까
오히려 빅테크들이 반등이 들어가는
모습은 그동안에 빅테크들의 케펙스가
오급등을
하나 급정을 하나 했던 부분이 아침에
말씀드렸듯이 가격이 너무 올라서
오히려 메모리 쪽에 가격이 떨어진다고
하면 빅테크들의 케팩스에 대한 부담이
좀 줄어들고 케펙스 금액이 줄어들면
그 빅테크 기업들의 프리캐시플로
수년금 흐름이 오히려 개선이 되다
보니까 약간 이제 실속 게임에 들어간
거 아닌가
같습니다.
그러면서 소프트웨어 기업들 엠빈 같은
것도 올라왔고 구글은 다우 지수의
편입니다. 그
>> 네
>> 어제 밤에 편입이에요. 오늘 밤에
편입이에
어제 밤에 편입이 된 것으로 알고
있습니다.네
>> 편입되면서
구글도 좀 구글도 그동안에 좀 많이
빠졌었죠. 좀 빠졌는데 4.8%
이렇게 좀 회복하는 모습이고
좌우지 수자체에 편입되는 거는 뭐
그렇게
수급에 큰 영향을 주는 이슈는
아닙니다.
자, 비트코인도 6만 회복을 했네요.
장비 역시 반도체에서는
장비가 강하네. 중국도 장비가 아니고
>> 맞요.
>> 어플라이 머티리얼 같은 경우에는
중국에도
매출 노출도가 한 20% 됐었던가?
맞아요. 그 뭐 그냥 요즘에 계속
줄이고 있잖아요. 이거 교재 때문에
줄이고 있는데 원는
>> 이렇게 동조 되는 거는 뭐 상상하지
못했어요. 왜냐면 충구는 지금 XMT
이런 YMT 정하면은 70% 80%
충비 자기 자 뭐 자겠다고 그렇게
얘기했잖아요.
그래서 뭐 여긴저 보면은 뭐
해외까지도 확정되는 거 같아요. 뭐
수요집.
>> 네. 그리고이 장비주는 미치가 사면은
장비 가도구라 할 수 있어요. 아마
지금은 이것 때문에 그냥 주가 몸통분
>> 장비 가격이 올라간다고
>> 맞아요. 다 인프레션이잖아요.
그죠? 매물 가격도 다 올랐는데
장비업체들 입장에서는 우리도 장비
가격 좀 올려볼까? 뭐 중국 업체들도
지르고 한국 업체들도 질러되고 하는데
>> 우리도 장비 쇼티지 얘기하면서
>> 가격 한번 올려 볼까 할 수도 있겠네
보니까. 어
자 그리고 52조 신고가에서 램
리서치도 있고 어플라이드 머티리얼도도
있고 그다음에 밑에 코닝 말씀하셨듯이
별주 부전에서 예 확실히 별주
부전에서 얘기한 종목이 나오니까 어
지금 어떤 상황에서 주가가 52주
신고가지 알겠네요.요 약간
밸류에이션이 비싸다고 해서 지금 당장
매수하는 것보다는 조금 기다렸다가
조정받으면 매수할 만하다. 요게
결론이었던 걸로 그 기어가 하는데
좀 기다렸다가 사야지 하면 일단은
1부은 보내 놔야 돼. 1부는 사
놓고 좀 기다리면 더 떨어지면 더
사야지 해야지.
15.7% 7% 나올
습니다. 자 그러면 가성화폐 시장으로
넘어가 보도록 하겠습니다.
네. 각성당시 말씀드리겠습니다. 가격
어제 아까 말씀해주신 것처럼 한 6만
물 정도를 다시 회복했습니다. 큰
이슈가 하나 있었는데요. 스트레티지가
비트코인이 계속 안 팔겠다라는
전략으로 가고 있었는데 어 비트코인에
대해서 어 유동화 계획을 좀 발표를
했습니다. 그 안에 있던 핵심
내용들은 비트코인을 팔아서 배당을
지급하거나 아니면 지금 현재 갖고
있는 MSTR 주주들의 환원을 위해서
어 다시 약간 주식을 재미입하는 그런
프로그램을 제기할 수 있다라는 것들이
발표가 되면서 너무 늦은감이
없잖아.이 있지만 어쨌든 지금
주주들의 어 환심을 조금 살 수 있는
그런 정책들을 발표를 하게 되면서 어
좀 불확실성이 회소됐다라고 시장에서
보고 있는 거 같습니다. 그래서 이게
어 당 중단 중장기적으로는 결국
루나테라 사건과 똑같은 거 아니냐.
그리고 이제 연구배상 연구선주에
배당률을 맞춰 주기 위해서 연구선주를
사 주는 그 이렇게 팩을 맞추려고
하는 그런 흐름으로 가는 거
아니냐라는 의심도 지금 현재 남아
있는 상태인데요. 그럼에도 불구하고
단기적으로 불확실성이 해소됐다라고
보고 있기 때문에 어 6만 불을 다시
회복했다. 5만 6만 불을 이탈했다가
다시 회복했다이 정도 보시면 될 거
같습니다. 오른쪽인 비트코인 장기
차트는 현재의 흐름 비슷하게 유지되고
있습니다. 지속해서 말씀드리고 있지만
65,000불 정도를 회복하지
못한다라고 하면 어 장기적으로
우아양한 추세를 기록할 수 있다라는
점 저게 참고해서 가면 될 거
같고요. 지금 비트코인 이렇게 빠지고
있는데 그러면 다른 알트코인들이나 어
다른 코인들에 대해서는 가격이
좋아지는 거 아닐까 이런 의심을
저희가 해 볼 수가 있을 것 같은데
원래는 순서대로 항상 보면 비트코인이
오르고 그다음에 알트코인이 오르기
때문에 그런 의심이 드는데요. 지금
비트코인이 빠지는데도 불구하고
비트코인 도미넌스 비트코인이 시장에
차지하고 있는 비중은 점점 올라가고
있습니다. 그러면 그게 무슨 뜻이냐?
결국에 이번에는 알트코인 장은 크게
없었고 비트코인이 점점 줄
흘러내리면서 그에 따라동조화되고 있고
시장에서 비트코인 차지하는 비중은 더
올라가고 있다. 지금 결국에
제도권으로 알트코인들이나 뭐 코인들
프로젝트를 약간 올리려고 하는 그런
흐름들이 클레이트 액트나 지니스
액트를 통해서 진행이 되고 있는데
그러면서 필터링이 많이 되게 될
겁니다. 어 뭐 사업을 못 하는 뭐
프로젝트들 돈 실제로 못 버는 그런
코인들 진짜 민코인 같은 것들은 다
없어질 거기 때문에 그런 부분들이
비트코인 도미넌에서 영향을 미치고
있다 이렇게 보시면 될 거 같고요.
비트코인 엔드 인덱스는 현재 시장을
잘 대변하고 있듯이 한 12 정도
익스트리언 구간을 기 지나고
있습니다. 스트레티지 업데이트를 한번
드리면 될 거 같은데요. 쓰레기지가
어 거의 한 1,200만 주를
MSTR를 ATM을 했습니다.
그러니까 시장에서 신주 발행을
했다라고 보시면 될 거 같은데요.
이러면서 한 25빌년 정도
아 2.5빌년 정도 US 그 달러 그
현금을 지금 확보를 했다라고 보시면
될 거 같고이 정도 달러 현금을
계속해서 유지를 하겠다라고 합니다.
그래서 지금 현재 지금 스트레티지가
어 그 연구선주 배당을 위해서 줘야
되는게 한 1.8빌리언 정도가
되는데요. 그걸 위해서 그 이상의
현금을 항상 확보하겠다라고 발표를
이번에 하게 되었고 그 재단 그
재원은 이번에는 MSTR 어 주식을
ATM을 하는 어 그런 그 툴을
이용했다라고 보시면 될 거 같고
그래서 어제 스트레티지와 그
스트레티지의 연구 우선주인 STC는
각각 12% 14% 다 어 급반등하는
모습을 보여주셨었습니다. 그래서 밑에
내려와서 보시면 주요시 한 가지를
말씀을 드리면 될 거 같은데요. 어
그레이 스케일이 어 비트코인 시에서는
가장 오래된 어 펀드입니다. 그러니까
어 기관 입장에서 뭐 블랙락이나 뭐
모건스텐 이런 기업들은 지금
최근에서야 막 들어오고 있는 거고
그레이 스케일은 2013년 13년도에
비트코인이 나온지 한 2년 정도밖에
안 됐을 때부터 뭐 비트코인 펀드를
만든다든가 하면서 비트코인을 계속 어
팔로우해 온 어 그런 기업이다라고
보시면 될 거 같고 A는 한 25일년
정도 되는 기업입니다. 어 현재
조정은 하락장의 시작이 아니라 시장
구조 변화로 인한 새로운 국면이다라는
식의 어 새로운 비율를 하나 제기해
줬는데요. 어, 비트코인 최근 가격
조정은 비트코인 상승하는 장기
추세선을 중심으로 발생한 또 하나의
주기적 조정에 해당한다라고 언급을 해
주면서 크립토 시장에 현재 세 가지
이슈가 있다. 첫 번째 클리트 액제
법안 불확실 불확실성 그리고 두
번째는 스트레티지의 대체 대조표에
가해진 압박. 세 번째 양자 컴퓨터
경계심이 있다라고 합니다. 어 하지만
크립토를 뒷받침하는 광범위한 사회적
정치적 트렌드 역시 확고하게 자리를
잡고 있다라고 하는데요. 어 그 정보
부채는 사실 계속 점진적으로 증가를
하고 있는 것이고 중계 기간의 신뢰도
하락하고 있고 마지막으로 신기술
신기술과 대한적 결제 시스템의
필요성을 자극하는 AI의 등장이다라고
합니다. 결국 이게 비트코인을
자극하는 건 아니지만 뭐 스테이블
코인이나 크리토신 자체를 조금 부양할
수 있는 그런 흐름이다라고 언급을
해줬고요. 그래서 이번 약재장을
벗어날 수 있는 두 가지 시나리오가
있다라고 하는데 그시길에서 보는
베이스 시나리오는 클레스가 통과가
되고 스트레티지의 대차대 조표가
강화되는 조치가 나오고 이렇게 나온
뷰가 나오자마자 어제 스트레티지가
이런 발표를 하게 돼서 조금 놀라웠긴
했었습니다. 그리고 연준의 금리
인상이 보류되는게 가장 베이스
케이스다라고 합니다. 다운사이드로는
클레티액트가 내년으로 좀 지연되는 거
그리고 DAT 기업들 뭐 스트레티지를
포함한 다양한 기업들의 디레버리징
문제가 심화되는 거. 그래서
마지막으로는 인플레이션으로
인플레이션에 의한 패드의 금리 인상
결정이 확정이 되는 것이지
다운사이드다. 이렇게 된다라고 하면
조금 어 약세가 좀 지속되다가
그다음에 반등할 수 있다. 이런
식으로 어 제기를 해 줬다라고 보시면
될 거 같고요. 어 그레이스게은
암호화폐 자산군의 중장기 전망이 좀
낙간적이다라고 설명을 해 주면서
장기적인 관점을 지닌 투자들에게는
현재 지금 매력적인 구간이다라고
설명을 해 줬습니다. 어 그 가장
결정적인 마지막 문장이었던 거
같은데요. 지난 2년간 금과
비트코인의 상대적 변동성이 각각이
22% 47%였던 것을 감안을 하면
한다라고 하는 금이 지금 고점 대비
한 26% 정도 빠졌더라고요. 그래서
현재 비트코인이 한 53% 정도
빠졌다 보니까 그 조정의 정도가
금이랑 지금 비트코인이랑 거의
비슷하게 가고 있다라는 점을 설명해
주고 있다라고 보시면 될 것
같습니다. 그래서 왼쪽 밑에 있는
비트코인 로그 차트와 트렌드미 사이클
이렇게 나와 있는데요. 어, 결국에
있는 그 약간 녹색 빛깔를 띄는이
선이 트렌드 선인데요.이 트렌드 선에
그냥 어, 같이 잘 올라타서 가고
있다라는 점을 설명을 해 주고 있고
가장 밑에 있는게 가장 중요했던 거
같은데요.이 사이클이 원래 어,
급격하게 위로 갔다 내려갔다 하면서
그 사이클이 어, 비트코인이 상승을
이끌었었는데 그 트렌드도 지금 굉장히
완만해지고 있고이 사이클도 그
변동폭이 좀 완만해지고 있다라는 것을
그레이스에서 좀 설명해 주고 싶었던게
아닌가 하는 생각을 하고 있습니다.
그래서 아까 제가 스트레티지 관련해서
간단하게 말씀을 드렸었는데
스트레티지가 어제 디지털 크레딧
캐피탈 프레임업이라고 하는 것을
발표를 하게 되면서 결국에는 지금
2.5빌리언 달러 정도의 현금을
만들었고 그거를 지금 한 배당 한
18개월 정도 줄 수 있다라고 하고
있고 비트코인을 이제 계속해서 판매를
할 수 있다라는 점을 언급해
줬습니다. 비트코인을 우리가 판매를
할할 때는 어 연구 우선주를 사거나
아니면 그 MSTR 그 스트레테지
주주들의 주주 환원을 위해서 사게
된다라고 언급을 했고 어 비트코인을
살 때 항상 비트코인 팔 팔게 될 때
항상 그 이사회의 사인을 받아야
된다. 그 승인을 받아야 된다라고
언급을 해 주면서 단기적인 변 그
단기적인 좀 리스크가 해소된게 아닌가
하는 생각을 했습니다. 제가 제목을
이번 사이클 피날레의 주인공이 될
생각이 없다라고 다 어 적어 놓은
이유는 뭐냐면 이대로 간다라고 하면
미실현 손익이 계속해서 어 더 깊게
찍히면서 스트레티지는 연구 우선주를
어 자금 조달 수단으로 쓰고 있었는데
연구 우선주를 자금 조달 수단으로
쓰지도 못하는 상황을 계속해서 직면실
수도 있습니다. 그렇게 된 그럼에도
불구하고 어제 어 유동화 계획을
발표를 하게 되면서 좀 단기적인
리스크를 해소하고 조금 더 수명을
연장했다라고 좀 표현을 하고
싶은데요. 어 그렇게 하면서 조금 어
연명을 하는 그 그림을 보여줬다라고
보시면 될 거 같습니다. 이상입니다.
>> 예. 반갑습니다. 딱 질문 하나만
하고 끝낼게요. 제일 위에 비트코인
장기 차트 있잖아요.
>> 네.이 이 장기 차트를 보면서
바닥에서 거래량이 급정을 하면서
지난번에 22년 조정에서 거래가
터지고 그다음에 올라왔는데
>> 지금 이번에 보니까 아직 거래가 없이
지금 빠지고 있는 모습이라서 이번에도
거래 터지는 모습 나오고 나서 사면
되나 이런 생각이 드는데네
>> 그 23년 22년 23년 이때 갑자기
과연이 좀 터졌던 거는 그
>> 어 ETF가 승인이 됐던 부분도 있
승인에 대해서 얘기가 계속 나왔던
부분이 있습니다. 그래서 그때부터
거래량이 확 터지게 되면서 어
그리고이 하락하면서 거래량이 터진
것도 있거든요. 그때 FTS 파산
상태가 터지면서 하락하는 거래량이 확
터지면서 어 조금 바닥을 잡았고 그
이유는 ETF 승인 관련해서 거래량이
확 터졌었는데요. 이번에는 이번에도
거래량이 터져야 뭔가 상승할 수 있을
거라는 생각을 하고 있지만 그
촉매제는 제가 무엇인 차지 잘 못
하고 있는데 원래는 가장 유력했던
후보가 스트리테이지가 거의 파산에
가까운 절차를 밝게 되는 것이 하나의
거래량이 터지는 이슈라고 봤었는데
어제 살짝 수명을 연장하는 그런 흐름
보셨다 이렇게 보시면 될 것
같습니다.네
>> 알겠습니다.네 모니무 리포 1부
순서는 여기까지 하고요. 잠시 후
2부 순서 이성준 대표가 진행을 해
주시겠습니다. 고맙습니다.
[음악]
>> [음악]
>> อ
안녕하십니까 채미턴 여러분. 행복한
투자을 함께하는 체슬리 무닝 브리프
6월 30일 2부 시작하겠습니다.
오늘 저 점이 이제 외부에 설명회가
오전에 있으셔서 1부 2부 순서
진행을 바꿔서 오늘 진행해 보고
있습니다. 어 2부 시작할 텐데요.
1부에서 우리 유리프로가 잘 정리해
주셨지만 조금 더 자세한 내용을
로호사장과 함께 알아보겠습니다.
사실 자세한 내용은 아니고요. 오늘
오늘 진짜 그 소재가 별로 없어
가지고
>> 네. 아침에 조금 힘들었는데
>> 아 일단은 뭐 지금 일어나고 있는
현상이
계속될지 아니면 어이 그 계절성에
의해서 어 단기적일지에 대한 판단이
되게 중요할 것 같아요. 어제 뭐
우리나라 시장에서도 나타났지만 그동안
그 소외됐던 종목들의 급등이 나타나고
또 많이 올랐던 종목들이 이제 조정이
나타났지만 미국 시장에서도 비슷한
현상이 나타나고 있는데 제가 보는
관점은 일단 아 이번 주가 월말,
본기말, 상반기말이 마무리되는
시점이고 또 기관 투자자들이
포트폴리오 리밸런싱에 대한 욕구가 클
것이기 때문에 나타나는 시장
변동성이라고 생각합니다. 그리고
주의해야 될 거는이 시장 변동성을
지나치게 확대해석하거나 과민하게
반응할 필요는 없다고 생각합니다.
사실 어제도 그렇고 뭐 어제 우리나라
시장도 그렇고 오늘 미국 시장도
그렇고 급등하거나 조금 빠지는
종목들의 이유를 찾기가 좀 어려운
상황이 많이 발생하잖아요. 뭐 단지
수급적인 요인이나
또는 심리적인 요인, 계절적인 요인
이런 정도로 해석을 어 저는 하고
있고요. 그리고 오늘이 마지막
날이니까 어 7월 초부터는 어느 정도
이런 부분들이 정리가 되면은 어 다시
펀더멘탈에 의한 어 종목 설명이나
시장에 대한 설명이 가능해질 거라고
생각을 하고 있습니다. 아, 그래서
일단 나타난 현상들만 보면은 M7이
상당히 그 올해
상반기에 어, 쉬었고
그리고 그 동일가중 지수를 추종하는
RSP
가에 조금 올라오고 있고요. 어
스파이도 어 조금 뭐 반등을 하고
있는 상황인데 RSP보다는 좀 덜하고
아직 미미하지만 그리고 소스가 좀
최근에 쉬고 있고 QQ큐Q가 좀 쉬고
있습니다. 근데 보시면은 최근 오일
흐름 보면은
어 M7이 한 2.4%
반등을 했고요. RSP 동일 가중이
0.5% 그리고 스파이가 어 0.3%
소스가 -3.6% % 정도가 하락을
했고요. qQ가 -3.0.3%.
근데 밑에 이제 소스하고음
>> q큐q큐가 그래도 주요 지수나 테마
쪽에서 보면은 어 올해 많이 올랐던
종목들입니다. 아 뭐니 그 ETF니까
종목이죠. 소스가 올해 104%
올라왔고 QQQ가 17.87% 8,
7% 올랐습니다. 그래서 아 그간
올랐던 종목들의음
조정이 나타나고 그간 소외되 있던
종목들의 어 반등이 좀 나타나고 있는
그런 국면이라고 보면 될 거 같고요.
저는 이게 그렇게 오래 가지 않을
거라고 생각을 하고 있고 어 실적
발표 시즌이대
그 시작되면은 어 분명히 그런
부분들에 의해서 어 다시 어
펀더멘탈에 따라서 주가의 방향성이 어
결정되지 않을까라고 생각을 하고
있습니다. 좀 뭐 우수갯 소리로
얘기하면은 어 SXX가 좀 빠진 거는
많이 오은 죄라고 생각합니다. 그래서
한두대 정도 맞고 가는 그런
국면이라고 생각을 하고 있습니다.
뱅크 아메리카에서 최근에 자료를
보면은이
회사 계속해서 그 전략 쪽에서는 어
작년 하반기부터 계속 역발상을
얘기하고 있는 회사거든요. 많이 오른
거 팔고 어 적게 옳은 거 사고
소외되는 거 사고 그러면서 이제 바벨
전력을 계속 얘기하고 있는데 어 안
맞고 있습니다. 안 맞고 있기 때문에
어 계속 무리 무리수를들은 느낌이
있고요. 얼마 전에 뱅크리카에서 나온
그 매크로 전략을 보면은 올해 뭐 세
번 정도 어 금리 인사을 할 수
있다는 주장을 펼치면서 어 시장의
어떤 이슈 시장에 관심을 한 몸에
받았었는데 사실 조금 맞지 않는
얘기인 거 같고요. 어 계속해서 그런
그 시각에 초점을 맞추다 보니까 좀
확증 편향에 빠진듯한 느낌이
있습니다. 그래서 어 그런 조정론에
근거해서 어 계속해서 자료를 내고
있는데 어쨌든 우리는 어 반대쪽에
있는 그 의견도 좀 살펴봐야 되기
때문에 어 최근에 나온 자료를 좀
보면은요. 미국시 주식 시장의
리스크오프 조건에 대해서 어 얘기를
하고 있는데음
뭐 시장이 정점이 픽아웃돼서 좀
빠지는 요건이 될 수 있는 어
트리거가 뭐가 있느냐라고 얘기를 하고
있는데 어 일단은 지금 어 위에 이제
그 동그라미 쳐 놓은 거 보면은
MAHS라고 해서 이게 메그니프슨 7
이거를 이제 동일 비중으로 투자하는
ETF인데 지금 63불의 거래가 가
되고 있습니다. 근데이 뱅크니카에서
얘기하고 있는 거는이 메그니투슨 7
ETF가 60%를 하향 돌파할 때
시장이 어 리스크오프가
시작됐다는 트리거로 봐야 된다라고 어
얘기를 하고 있습니다. 그래서
>> 다분이 좀 기술적인 느낌이 강하고요.
그 파란 줄로 쭉 그어서 어 60불을
정도를 트리거로 봐서이 60불이 어
M7이 깨지게 되면은 어 더 이상
얘네들이 어 케팩스를 늘릴 수 없는
지경에이를 것이다라는 그 관점으로음이
주가를 해석을 하고 있는 거 같고요.
그리고 엔화 대비 호주 달러가
110불을 하향 돌파할 때데 어
S&P 500하고 좀 겹쳐서 그려
보니까 어 110불을 하향 돌파할 때
SP이 조금 조정을 받기는 했어요.
근데 뭐 그게 기조적 조정은 아니고
어 길게 보면은 계속 어 SP
500은 우상향을 했는데 어쨌든
단기적으로는 아마 호주 달러 하면은
호주 이제 그 원자재가 많이 나다
보니까 어 위험 자산의 대표적인
통화로 어 상징이 되잖아요. 엔화는
어 그 안전 자산의 대표 통화로 그
상징이 되고 그래서 어 호주 달러가
110불 엔화 대비 호주 달러가
110불을 하향 돌파할 텐데 어 이게
그 호주 달러가 위험 자산의 대표적인
어 통화가 되다 보니까 어 110불을
하향 돌파하게 되면은 어쨌든 위험
자산에 대한 선호가 어 줄어드는 거로
어 봐야 된다. 위험 해피로 봐야
된다라고 얘기를 하고 있습니다.
그리고이
부분은 저도 계속해서 관찰하고 있는
상황인데 어 최근에 연준의 그
스탠스가 약간 호키시아라는 평가에
의해서 단기 금리가 조금 올라가고 어
장기 금리는 조금 내려오고 하는 그런
현상이 나타다 보니까 장단기 금리차가
어 최근에 한 0.5% 이상 기록을
했었는데 0.28%까지 28%까지
내려왔습니다. 그래서 전통적으로 그
장단기 금리차가 역전에 되면은
리세션에 들어갈 수 있다는 뭐 당장은
아니더라도 시차를 두고 리세션에
들어갈 수 있다는
이론들이 있잖아요. 그런 거를 염두해
두고 어 장단기 금리차 역전을
얘기하고 있는 거 같습니다. 근데
결론적으로 아직까지는 위에 세 조건을
>> 감안을 할 때
>> 어 어느 한 조건도 맞는 조건이 없기
때문에 아직 시장은 정점을 인식하는
단계는 도달하지 않았다. 아직 리스크
업프 단계는 아니다라고 해석을 할
수가 있을 것 같습니다.
그리고 아까 이제 결국에는이
그 리스크 오프의 조건 중에 하나가
저는 가장 그 중요한 것이 그리고
이제 시장의 색깔이 변하는 것도 어
그 맥락을 같이 할 수가 있을 것
같은데 어 빅테크가 너무 많이 그
케팩스 투자를 해 가지고 더 이상 할
수 없을 정도로 그 하거나 아니면은
그 케펙스 투자를 줄이거나 할 때가
아 약간 시장의 색깔이 변하거나
리스크오프의 어떤 시점이 될 거
같은데 어 그런 차원에서 어 이번에
실적을 발표하는 하이퍼스케일러들
[목을 가다듬음]
그러니까 마이크로소프트나 아마존이나
아 구글이나 어 메타 이런 쪽에 어
영업 이익률하고
케펙스가 얼마나 증가하는지 보면은 어
결론부터 말씀드리면은 케펙스가 어
가속화되면 됐지 어 줄이 줄어들
여지는 크게 없다라고 일단 시장에서
어 예상을 하고 있고요. 물론
그 실적을 발표했을 때 아, 요거보다
어, 정 많 적냐 적 많으냐 뭐 이런
거를 따지게 되겠지만 제 그
느낌상으로는
이거보다 많으면 많았지 적을 것 같진
않습니다.
>> 일단 뭐 펀더멘탈을 나타내는 영업
이익률하고 케펙스만 좀 동시에
보면은요. 어, 마이크로소프트 같은
경우는 대략적으로 그 영업 이익률이
44.7% 정도. 어,
마이크로소프트는 이번에 6월로 끝나는
그 회계 기간이 어, 4분기입니다.
44.7%가
나올 걸로 예상이 되고 있고 전년
동기는 44.9%였습니다.
살짝 어, 전년 동기보다는 0.2%
2% 포인트 하락하는 아 2% 포인트
하락하는 걸로 돼 있고요. 케펙스는
34.9
빌리언 달러를 예상하고 있는데 YY로
104.7%고
어 그리고 그 이후에는 그 차분기에는
어떻게 될 것인가를 보면은 어
130%가 느는 거로 돼 있습니다.
그래서 어 44.6빌리언 6빌리언
달러를 어 집행을 할 걸로 예상이
되고 있는데
26년 1분기에는 어 19.39 상빌
달러였습니다. 그래서 상승률만 증가
율말로만 보더라도 어 분기별 케펙스
YY 증가율은 더 가속화된다라고
보시면 될 거 같고 아마존은
어 지금 영업 이익률이 한 12%
정도 나올 걸로 예상 되고 있고 전년
동기는 11.4%였습니다.
어 케펙스는 48.5빌리언이고
Yi로 한 50.6% 6% 정도
증가하는 거 증가할 걸로 시장에서는
보고 있고요. 3Q가 51. 어
76빌리언 달러인데
Yi로 47.4% 4% 정도 어
늘어나는 거로 돼 있습니다. 그래서
위에 이제 그 해놓고 왔는데
마이크로소프트에 그래서 어 프리케시
플로우 같은 경우는 어 그 회계년도
4분기에 15빌리언에서 어 그다음
분기 10빌리언으로
그 줄어들긴 하지만 아직 마이너스는
아니고요.
아마존 같은 경우는 어 프리캐시
플로우가 이번까지는 플러스를 기록하고
어 다음 그까 그다음부터는 어
-7빌리언으로 마이너스로 들어가게
됩니다.
>> 어 구글 같은 경우는 어 영업기률
34.7%를
기록할 거로 예상을 하고 있고요.
전년 동기가 32.4%였습니다.
그리고 케펙스는 43.95%로
아 95 빌리언 달러로 95.8%가
8%가 전년 동기 대비 늘어나는 거로
돼 있고요. 3Q에는 50.0
빌리언인데 계산해 보면은 109%가
늘어나는 거로 돼 있습니다. 그래서
구글 역시 캠팩스가 가속화될 걸로
보고 있고요. 메타 같은 경우가
영업 이익률 35.7%인데 7%인데
전년 동기가 43%였습니다. 그래서
>> 어 [콧방귀] 이익률 자체가 뚝
떨어지는 걸로 보고 있고 최근에 이제
메타 관련돼서 어 뉴스가 나오고 있는
거는 어 비싸게 영입한 인재가 그
역할을 제대로 못 하고 있다라는
내부적인 어떤 반성들이 좀 나오고
있는 상황이고요. 그런 것들로
미뤄보어서 약간 전략 자체를 어
수정할 가능성도 있지 않을까라고 어
보고 있습니다. 케펙스는
33.6빌리언인데
103%가 Yi로 증가하는 걸로 돼
있고 어 그다음 분기는 110%가
늘어나서 39.6밀리언 6빌리언
달러를 기록할 걸로 시장에서는 보고
있습니다. 그래서 어 캡펙스 아 그
프리플 프 프 프리캐시플로 같은
경우가
멘타가 지금 마이너스로 어 들어갔고
어 다음 분계도 마이너스가 될 걸로
보고 있고 그리고 위에 아까
아마존이 다음 분기에는 마이너스
그리고 어 플러스를 여전히 어 줄
줄어들곤 있지만 프리캐시블로가
플러스를 유지하고 있는데는 어
마이크로소프트하고 어 구글 정도가 될
것 같습니다. 그래서 어 여전히
그 케펙스에 대한음
증가 속도 자체는 어 계속해서 좀 어
가속화되고 있다라고 보시면 될 거
같고 그에 따라서 어 아주 뭐 우려할
정도는 아니지만 일부
하이퍼스케일러들이
자유 현금 흐름 자체가 어 음으로
들어가기 시작했다라고 보시면 될 것
같습니다.
>> 네.
감사합니다. 장님이 또 꼼꼼하게
실적과 브리캐시 블로우리 아
프리뷰죠.
지 해주셨는데요. 우선 먼저
위에서부터 쭉 내려올 때
>> 예
>> 어 연초만 해도 어 마켓 브로드닝
이런 얘기를 굉장히 많이 하고 이제
M7 주가가 좀
>> 흐지부지하고 그 밑에 단들이
올라오면서 동일가중 지수가 어이 가중
평균 시가총액 그 가중 시가 총액
비중 지수보다 이제 좋아지면서
>> 그런 얘기가 가다가 어느덧 그런
얘기도 흐지부지되고 그렇다고 M7이
주가가 좋은 건 아닌데 예. 그
밑단에 있는 어 밑단이라고 해봤자
대부분 다 반도체 관련주 그것과
관련된 인프라 이런 것들이 이제
올라오면서 어 시장을 어떤 한 단어로
정의하기가 좀 애매해지니까
이제 뱅크 오브 아메리카에서 또 다른
이제 말들을 좀 만들어 내고 뭐 이제
그런 중인데요. 우리 부사장님이 뱅크
오브 아메리카 얘기를 해 주실 때
어이 표정에서 이미 마음에 안 들
옆에서 보니까 이제 보이는데
>> 계속 틀리니까네
>> 제가 그 어 약간 그래도 뱅크 편해서
좀 편을 좀 빌자면 저희가 이제
업무적으로 [목을 가다듬음]
전문적 투자를 위해서 얘기할 때도
그렇고 지인들 만났을 때도 어 시장이
올라가는 거야, 내려가는 거야?
아니면 뭐 삼성전자를 지금 사야 되는
거야, 팔아야 되는 거야 이런 얘기를
할 때 [콧방귀]
어 물어본 사람과 대답하는 사람의 어
약간 그 핀트 그니까 초점이 안 맞는
경우가 사실은 그 앞에
>> 어 나에 대한 의견이 어느 정도
기간에 대한 생각인지
>> 그 기간에 대한 얘기를 좀 빼고
얘기하는 경우가 많아서
>> 그렇습니다. 그래서 아주 아주
극단적으로 SMP 500이 50년
후에 지금보다 오르는 거야, 내리는
거야. 그러면 아마 거의 대부분의
사람이 예외 없이 오른다고 얘기할 때
>> 기간이 짧아질수록 이제 분산돼서
>> 어 오른다는 사람 내린다는 사람이 뭐
거의 5대 5일로 이제 가게 될 텐데
>> 어 우리 부사장님은 대부분의 경우는
어 제가 보는 주변의 전문적인 투자를
업으로 하는 분들 중에는 좀이 투자의
시계가 좀 긴 편에 속하시는 거
같아요. 그러다 보니까 어 항상 좀
긍정적으로 보고 어 악재가 나와서이
주가가 하락할 때 매수 기회를 삼고
이러는데 부사장님이 이해를 안 해
주셔도
>> 일주일짜리 한 달짜리 투자자들이
분명히 있습니다.
>> 아 그렇습니다. [웃음]
>> 그런 분들은 고민이 되죠. 예.
고민이 되죠. 그러다 보니까 또 이제
기술적인 것들을 보게 되고 [콧방귀]
>> 그러다 보니 그런 분들의 니즈에
맞춰서도 때로는 자료를 좀 발관해야
되는게 증권사의 어떤
>> 업무 중에 하나다라고 좀
>> 어 제가 B웨를 대변해서 [웃음]
>> 그 사장님께 양해를 좀 구하겠습니다.
>> 뭐 뭐 커넥션 있는 건 아니죠.
[웃음]
>> 네. 그런 건 아니고
>> 자료는 상당히 그 데이터 기반에서 어
정교하게
>> 어 잘 하는 거 같습니다.
>> 네. 그래서 여기 보면 이제 주식
시장이 위험피 심리가 확산될 수 있는
트리거 다시 얘기하면 주식 시장이
조정받을 수 있는 어떤
>> 촉매 그니까요 아래 동그라미를 해
주신 세 개다라고 얘기를 했는데 어
나는 이제 요런 것들을 좀 보면서
단기적으로 좀 조심해야 된다고
생각한다라는 의견을 주신 거 같아요.
그러다 보니까 어 아무래도이 이익이
동반된 성장이다 보니까 단기
과열이라고 하는 신호에 집중할 수밖에
없고
>> 그러다 보니까 이제 기술적으로 얼마나
이게 어
>> 저항선 레벨에 있느냐 아니면 지지선
레벨을 뭐 하향 돌파했냐 그런 얘기를
어 써 주셔야 되다 보니까이
MAGs라고 하는 M7 추종하는
ETF의 기술적 지표 넣어 주신 거
같고
>> 어 [콧방귀] 매크로 차원에서는 위험
자산 어 안전 자산 선호의 어떤
호불로가 이제 계속 바뀔 텐데 그런
거에 대해서 이제 N러 아 N화 대비
호주 달러 얘기해 주신 거 같고
장단기 금리차는 부사장님 제가
기억하기로 그냥 장단기 금리가
역전된게 좋은 거야 나쁜 거야라고
어떤 흑백 그러니까 이분법적으로
물어보면
>> 예
>> 장기 금리가 단기 금리보다 내려왔단
얘기니까
>> 예
>> 어 적절한 인플레이션 플러스 미래
기대 성장률이 어 깨졌다. 특히 이제
미래 기대 성장률이 깨졌다라는
관점에서는
>> 어 장당금 [콧방귀]
금리가 역전된게 좋은 거야, 나쁜
거야라고 물어보고 꼭 둘 중에 하나로
대답해 그러면 나쁜 거야라고
얘기하는게 맞는 거 같아요.
>> 예, 그렇습니다.
>> 그런데 요게 또
>> 정설이죠.
>> 예, 디테일로 들어가면 해석의 여지는
좀 항상 좀 있을 수 있는 거죠.
>> 예, 그렇습니다. 어떤 그러니까
교과서적으로 보면 장단기 금리차는 그
아, 플러스이어야 맞죠. 왜냐면은 어
내가 10년짜리 채권을 사는 거하고
어 2년짜리 채권을 사는 거 중에서
10년 동안에 무슨 일이 일어날지
모르니까 당연히 좀 더 높은 어
수익률을 요구하는게 맞는 거고
2년짜리는 그보다 좀 상대적으로
기간이 짧으니까 어 적은 수익률을
요구하는게 맞는 건데 어떤 구간에
있어서는 어 이게 선호도가 잠깐잠깐
단기적으로 좀 바뀌는 경우가 가 아
있어서 어 그게 좀 역전되는 경우가
있는데 그 역전되는
그 현상만 보고 이게
>> 앞으로 장 앞으로 경기 침체에 들어갈
위험이 있다. 이렇게 좀 해석하는
사례들이요
몇 년간 몇 번 있었습니다. 근데 어
장당김체가 실제로 역전됐을 때 어 왜
침체가 오지? 침체가 오지? 침체가
안 오지? 어 이런 그 의구심을
사람들이 가졌었는데 아 그 침 그
역전된 거의 이제 기저에는 어 특정한
특정한 어 그 기관물에 대한 어
손호가 있었던 걸로 제가 기억을 하고
있거든요. 그래서
>> 그냥 일반적으로는 역전이 뭐 그렇게
좋은 건 아니지만
>> 어 그 기저에
>> 어 단기적으로 어 다양한 요인이 있을
수 있다. 그렇게 이해를 하시면 될
것 같습니다. 최근에 그 저희
모닝브리 1부나 2부 때 좀 언급이
없어서 제가 궁금해서 여쭤봤는데요.
>> 최근에 미국의 국채가
>> 계속해서 이렇게 차원 발행 그
리파이네이션도 되고 새로 그
>> 어 발행하기도 하고 할 텐데
>> 입찰은 좀 어떻습니까?
>> 입찰 아 응찰이요? 응응찰 꽤 아
좋습니다. 평균 이상입니다.
>> 그러면 그러면 상대적으로는 조금 낮게
금리를 가져갈 수 있겠다 입장에서
>> 그렇죠. 수요 자체가 어 상당히
괜찮고 그리고 제가 그 그 미국에서
이제 데이터 센터 관련된 딜에
참여하고 있는 은행의 한 관계자한테
물어보 최근에 이제 물어봤는데 어
데이터 센터 딜 자체가 여전히 핫하고
어 수요가 상당히 세다고 봅니다.
그래서 약간 약간 저 그 가끔씩
나오는 이제 뉴스의 노이즈하고는 조금
다르게 어 실제 상황에서는 그렇게 큰
우려는 없다라고 얘기를 하더라고요.
그래서
>> 여전히 저는
>> 뭐 AI 인프라에 대한 어떤 방향성
추세 요런 것들은 어 유효하지
않나라고 생각합니다.
>> 음
>> 알겠습니다. 밑에 이제 빅테크들 실적
프리뷰도 해 주시고 프리캐시 플로우의
어 흐름이 어떻게 되는지도 보여
주시는데이 흐름이 아무래도 투자를
많이 하다 보니까 프리캐시 플로우
흐름이 안 좋아지는 방향으로 가는 건
당연하고
>> 예
>> 어 보통 저희가 하이퍼스케일러 대여섯
개를 언급할 때 여기 써 주신 것들
그리고 플러스 오라클 뭐 정도를
얘기를 하는데 아마
>> 저도 그냥 언뜻 지나가면서 봤는데
오라클의 프리케시 블로우가 여기
보여주신 것 회사들보다는 상대적으로
좀 더 안 좋은 거 같아.
그렇습니다. 그래서
>> 어 캐시플로우가 마이너스가 나더라도
어 회사치를 발행해서라도 지금은
나중에 AI 플랫폼에 있어서 살아남을
어 두 세 개 정도에 남기 위해서
아직까지 투자를 좀 멈출 수 없는
상태인 거 같고
>> 지금의 투자가 어떤 모르겠습니다.
이렇게 자동차처럼
>> 이미 생산이
>> 어 수요보다 생산이 훨씬 많은데
>> 어 그럼에도 불구하고 내가 죄를
이기기 위해서 투자하는 단계라기보다는
>> 이게 얼마나 커질지 모르는 미래에
대해서 지금 투자를 해 가는 단계이기
때문에
>> 조금 더 지르는 거 같아요. 만약에
자동차 산업 같으면 제가 지금 한국에
한 200만대 공장을 더 만들겠다
하면
>> 정말 복잡한 계산을 해 봐야 되는데
얼마나이 그 묘수가 있느냐 이런
생각까지 해 봐야 되는데 약간 좀
다른 차원인 거 같아요.
>> 예. 그렇습니다. 그래서 이번에 또
어 체크해 봐야 될 것이 지금까지는
어 수요가 공급을 압도한다라는
코멘트들이 계속 하이퍼스러들한테
나왔었고요. 어 그렇기 때문에 어
투자를 멈출 수 없다라고 얘기를
했었는데 이번에도 그런 코멘트가
나오는지 한번 살펴봐야 될 것
같습니다. 예, 그래서 이게 저희는
지금 인프라사이클에 있어서 하드웨어,
특히 이제 반도체 기업들의 어,
시장이 주목을 하고 있는데 빨리 어떤
비즈니스 모델을 또 이런 빅테크들이
가져가는게 장기적으로는 또 선순환이지
않을까
>> 싶습니다.
>> 예.
>> 예. 사장님 자세한 자료 감사하고
항상 요렇게 큰 기업들 프리뷰를 해
주시니까 어 미리 좀 데뷔를 하고
미국장 열렸을 때 우리 서학개미
분들이 대응을 하실 텐데 실적보다는
K팩스 관심이 훨씬 많은 걸로 봐서는
빅테크보다는 반도체가 아직 시장의
화두구나라는 생각도 사이드로 좀 해
보게 됐습니다. 감사합니다. 미국
시장 여기까지 보고요. 한국 시장으로
넘어가 보겠습니다. 호과장님
부탁드립니다.
네. 전일 시작 말씀드리겠습니다.
[목을 가다듬음]
코스피 모압 정도 수준으로 마감을
했고요.
코스닥은 8% 급등세를 기록을 하면서
지수 차별화가 이번엔 좀 반대로 크게
나타났었던 거 같습니다.
그럼에도 불구하고 현재 코스닥 YT
수익률은 여전히 마이너스 수입권에
있는 상황이고 뭐 오늘 중에는 그래도
플러스 전환하지 않을까 싶습니다.
수급적으로 봐 주시면 개인 투자자가
4조 6천억량 매수세를 유입이 됐었고
외국인이 7조 넘게 매도를 했습니다.
매도 근무가 상당히 크게 나왔고요.
기관에 선원 한 3조 가까이 매수세가
유입이 되기도 했습니다.
투자자별 매매 동향으로 내려가서 보면
외국인 투자자는 어제 삼성전기를
1천억가량 매수를 했었고요.
반면에 LG 에너지 솔루션 그리고
두산 에너빌리티 LG노텍
삼성 바이오로직스 등의 종목들도 어
매수세가 좀 강하게 유입이
됐었습니다. 어 매도에는 삼성전자
3조 8천억 SK닉스 3조 3천억
매도하면서 거의 뭐이 두 종목에 대한
매도가 전부였다라고 볼 수 있을
정도로
>> 매도 규모가 상당히 크게 크게 나오고
있는 상황이고요. 그 외에는 SK
스퀘어, 현대중공업, 삼성 SDI,
이수페타시스, 주성 엔지니어링 등을
매수했습니다. 아, 매도했습니다.
>> 음. 기간 매수에는 삼성전자,
SK하이닉스, SK 스퀘어, 삼성
SDI, 주성 엔지니어링, 현대중업
등을 매수했고요. 매도 쪽에는 한미
반도체 그리고 HPSP, 원익 IPS
등을 매도했습니다.
52주 신고가 종목 총 여덟 종목이
나왔는데요. 코스피에서는 금설이
상한가를 기록을 했는데 제가 알기로는
>> 광주 쪽에 그리고 호남 호남 쪽에
네네. 그쪽에 이제 반도체 펩을 대거
짓는다. 어제
국회에서였나요? 그 방송 영상도
봤는데 400조씩 한다고 하더라고.
자 400조 하이닉스
>> 400조씩 하고 뭐 청주 쪽에 몇십조
그고
>> 부산 쪽 저쪽에도 한 몇십조 해서 총
1천원 가량에
>> 규모 투자를 한다고 하는데 뭐 그렇게
>> 현실화될지는 아직 정해진 건 아니지만
어쨌든 그런 이슈가 들리다 보니 뭐
관련주의 주가도 상당히 좋았었다라고
볼 수 있을 것 같고요. 음
>> 코스닥에선 기가비스 뭐 인바디 SM
CNC 등이 어 신구가 이름을
올리면서 어 최근 코스닥에서 장비주
쪽에서는 기가비스 흐름이 좀 탄탄한
거 같습니다.
삼성전자 기준으로 2,000조 이상
투자 계획을 발표하면서 그 중
400조가 이제 호남이 돌아오네.
>> 그런 내용들이 어제 있었고
>> 어 우리 오가장 고양인 청주에도 투자
계획이 발표됐는데 오늘 왜 이렇게
힘이 없어요?
>> 네. 뭐 어제 밤에 파티에서 힘이
없어. 아니 피곤하시장 [웃음]
이게 좀 피곤하게 만드는 거
같습니다. 어 지수랑 그 투자자별
매매 동향에서 오가장한테 하나만 좀
물어보고 지나갈게요. 여기 외국인
기관 그 매수 매도 상위 종목들이 한
10여개씩 있는데 어 오과장이 쭉
이렇게 매일매일 우리 회사에서 가장
많은 리포트들 보고 시장 관련 뉴스들
보니까 어 수급이 아니라 개별 재료
그 단기 어떤 개별 뉴스나 펀더멘탈
변화에 대한 소식이 있어서 매수
매도가 크게 나온 것 같은 종목이
혹시 보이세요?
>> 전혀 안 보입니다.
>> 음. 그나마
솔브레인 같은 종목들
>> 소재 기업들 잘 안 보이거든요.이
외국인 매수상이
>> 네. 그 저렇게 190억 가려 작은
종목인데 이렇게 들어온 거 보면
집어서 사는 느낌이
>> 있었다. 어제
>> 그러면 이게 개별재료가 있었다기보다는
뭐 쇼커버일 수도 있고 아니면 평소
좋게 보다가 적감 매수했던 걸 수도
있고 그럴 수 있겠습니다. 그래서
저희가 요즘처럼 이렇게 매매가 큰
어떤 패시브, ETF 이런 어
수급들이 주도하는 장에서는 그것들을
좀 발라내고 어 매매를 좀 봐야
하는데 평의 종목들 잘 안 보이는 거
같아요. 그래서
>> 음
>> 실제로이 액티브 투자라고 부르는 개별
주식 투자를 하는 왕의사님 네
>> 어떻게 대응해야 됩니까?
>> 대응하기 어렵죠. [웃음]
>> 대응하기 어려운데요. 네. 어제
시장을 보면서 그 삼성전자 하이닉스를
시작하자마자 외국인들이 이제 많이
세게 팔았거든요. 그래서 아까 어
보과장이 얘기해 준 것처럼 두 종목
합해 가지고 한 7조 정도 매도가
나왔었어요. 그러다 보니까 상대적으로
삼성자 하이닉스가 눌려 있는 상태였고
다른 쪽으로 이제 수급이 어 예전하고
다르게 그동안하고 다르게 이제 다른
쪽으로 이제 수급이 이제 쏠렸던 거
같은데 아까 전에 말씀해 주셨던 어이
특징적으로이 종목별로 해서 봤을 때
아까 전에 솔브레인도 얘기가
나왔었는데 최근에 2차전지 쪽
관련돼서는 실적 터너라운드 관련된
얘기가 조금 조금씩 나와요. 음
>> 그래서 그런 것들 제외하고는 제가
봤을 때는 다 수급 영향이지
않을까라고 생각을 합니다. 네. 턴
턴 어라운드가 실적으로 빡빡 꼽히면서
주가 상승이 있어요. 진짜 세게
올라가는데 그런 부분들이 있는지 좀
기대해 보겠습니다. 다음 보겠습니다.
네. 반도체 섹터 먼저 살펴보면 어제
대형 반도체 주가 흐름이 장중에 계속
왔다 갔다 하는 지임이 나타났는데
삼성전선자는 좀 약하게 끝났던 거
같고 한 5% 가량 하락했고
하이닉스는 그래도 좀 많이
말아올리면서
마감했던 거 같습니다. 어쨌든 케팩스
투자에 대한 이야기가 어제 주를
이뤘는데 삼성전자가 2040년까지
뭐 2차전지 반도체 이런 거 다 해서
>> 음
>> 2,400조 가량을 투자를 하겠다라고
>> 했는데요. 뭐 메모리 쪽에 어떤
시계열로 얼마나 빠른 속도로 할지는
모르겠지만
그런 공격적인 케펙스 투자를이 메모리
업체들을 보는 투사자 입장에서는 좀
보수적으로 볼 수밖에 있지 않나라는
생각이
>> 어제 좀 그 영상을 다 봤는데요.
생방송으로 그런 생각이 좀 들었던 거
>> 같고
>> 아래 소부장 종목들의 경우는
[목을 가다듬음] 좀 최근에 계속
혼조센 거 같아요. 다 같이 오르는
흐름이 아니라 이쪽 올랐다고 하면 또
저쪽도 올라가고 이쪽 빠지고 산론
저쪽 올라가고 이런 움직임이
나타나는데 어제 장에서는 HPSP
그리고 리노 공업이 한 1%대
올라줬고요. 좀 강했던 종목은 주성
엔지니 6.6 SNS텍이 한 8%
가량 상승으로 마감을 했습니다. 사실
중국의 창신 메모리 상장이 이제
눈앞에 있다 보니 SNS텍이 중도가
상당히 높은 회사잖아요.
>> 음.
그런 부분이 조금씩 수급으로 들어오고
있지 않나 그런 생각이 들었고 진짜
어제 반도체 대형 반도체 빠지는 걸
보고 조금 불안하긴 했거든요. 왜냐면
금요일에 그렇게 시장의 급락을 다
같이 빠졌었다가 이제 월요일장에 그
반등 나오면 여태까지 한 6개월
1년간의 흐름을 보면 그럴 때 대형
반도체가 가장 세게 올라가었거든요.
어제는 시장이 반등함에도 불구하고
대원 반도체가 빠지는 모습을 보면서
앞으로 이전처럼 이렇게 폭발적인
상승을 우리가 기대하긴 힘들 수도
있겠다.
>> 사람들의 생각이 그래서
>> 사람들의 생각이 좀 변화 변화되고
있다.
>> 이전에 아 그냥 빠지면서 하얀
>> 그런 느낌은 아니야. 음,
>> 그런 생각을 좀 들었습니다.
IT 섹터 봐 주시면 삼성 전기가
2.2% 올랐고요. 그 외스플레이나
BH, 파인 M텍 등이 모바일 밴
모바일 쪽에 엮겨 있는들도 상승가 좀
강했고요. 어제 플랫폼 쪽도
좋았습니다. 뭐 네이버나 카카오
나머지 전도 대체로 강한
상승세였고요. 니케이 지수 어제 보합
정도로 마감을 했는데 어 우리
시장이랑 비슷했던 거 같아요.
금요일이 한 4% 빠지고 월요일장에
소폭 반등 정도 마감을 했는데 반도체
쪽이 그래도 조금씩 반등하는 모습은
나왔습니다. 도쿄 일렉트론이 2.4
그리고 어 호야가 0.9 디스코가
1.3% 오르면서 많이 빠졌던 종목들
그래도 조금이나마 반등하는
모습이었고요.
자동차 섹터 현대차 기아 한 3, 4
3% 상승 마감했고요. 어제 소비제
섹터가 상당히 좋았습니다. 뭐 특별한
이슈가 있었던 건 아니고요. 수급이
좀 퍼진 영향이 있던 거 같은데
대형화장품에서 아모래가 15%
급등세를 기록했고 생활 건강도 한
10% 올랐습니다. 그리고 아래 있는
뭐 중소형 5 ODM4들도 많이
올랐고요. 미용 기기도 상당히
좋았는데요. 클래시스, 파마, 휴젤,
AP 원택 적게는 6% 많게나 10%
이상 상승세를 보였고 덴티움이나 영업
무역도 모처럼 상승세 보였습니다.
음증 [목을 가다듬음] 섹터도 나쁘지
않았고요. 반면에 백화점 체인는 좀
무진했는데요. 뭐 기존에 워낙
강하기도 했었고
전에 말씀드렸지만 이거 반도체
관련주로 저는 생각하고 있기 때문에
전자닉스 빠지면 좀 같이 빠지는 지금
>> 나타났던 거 같습니다.
>> 조선 철감및 기타 섹터 봐 주시면
조선주들도 반등이 좀 크게
나타났고요. 여기도 호재가 있었던 건
아니고 적가 매수세가 좀 강하게
유입이 됐습니다. 아래 철강 화학
섹터도 뭐 마찬가지 흐름이었고
방산주는 뭐 상대적으로
다섹터 대비 좀 부진했는데요. 여로는
보합 정도로 마감하면서 좀 많이
아쉬운 하루였고 넥선도
마찬가지였습니다.
현대 로템 밸루에이션이 얼마나 더
낮다 보니 적의 수세가 방산주 대에서
이쪽으로 좀 집중됐던 거 같고요.
아래 원전이나 바이오섹터들도 상당히
좋았습니다. 어 대형 바이오잉 뭐
쌈바나 에피스 쪽 셀트리온도
좋았고요. 코스닥 쪽이 상당히
좋았는데 웨이빌, 바이오, 펩트론,
DND 등이 거의 20% 가까운
상승세 보였습니다. 그리고 그
금융주나 증권주도 좋았고요. 엔터
쪽도 모처럼 어 강한 상세
보였습니다. 한 10%대씩 다
올라줬고 변악기 쪽도 최근 한 달간
좀 안 좋았는데요. 어제장에 좀
반응이 강했습니다.
네.
>> [콧방귀]
>> 오른쪽에서 제가 이렇게 쭉 오장이
설명해 주실 때 종목들 쭉 보다
보니까음 대부분 다 그 저희가이 표를
보여 드릴 때 하락이 클수록 짙은
파란색 상승이 클수록 짙은 빨간색으로
표시해 드리는데
>> 어 오른쪽에서 유통주가 가장 빨개요
제가 그래서 어 우리 오과장은 반도체
관련주라고 얘기를 해 주셨던 기억이
나는데 반도체 [콧방귀] 관련주의든
외국인 관련주이든 외국인 관광
관련주이든 반도체 어, 유통업체들의
주가가 상당히 좋고 여기 표시 안 되
아마 루대 쇼핑이나 다른 유통
종목들도 비슷한 경향이지 않을까
싶습니다. 결국 어저께 하루만 보면
솔림이 그 수급적 솔림이 조금
완화되면서 어 상대적으로 뭐 P지
개념이 됐던 단기 분기실적 개념이
됐던 매력이 있다고 생각되는 쪽으로
수급이 이렇게 분산되다 보니까 시가
총액 60% 이상 유지하는 어
차지하고 있는 종목들에서 나온 수급이
나머지 3 40%에게 뿌려지다 보니까
개별 종목 상승폭가 굉장히 컸던 거
같습니다. 어 어저께 오후인지 오늘
아침인지 모르겠는데요. 제가 리포트를
쭉 보다 보니까 우리 문상무한테 하나
오늘 회의 끝나 물어보려고 했는데
지금 물어볼게
>> 그신증권의
유형근 위원님 저희가 가끔 이제 보는
안드 제널리스트인데
>> 어 제목 보니까
>> 어 미국의 이제 빅테크들이 한국의
삼성전자 하이닉스에게
어 견제고를 던졌다 이제 이런 표현을
쓰시면서 내용을 제가 헤들라인 본
것만 좀 요약을 하면 지금은 어쩔 수
없이 저희가 알고 있는 반도체
3사들에게 반도체 수급을 미국
빅테크들이 의존할 수밖에 없는데 어
반도체를 좀 일부 종국에서 좀 어
수급할 수 있다. 이런 얘기들이
나오면서 좀 가격 협상력을
어이 수요자 쪽에서 가져오고 싶어
하는게 아니냐 아니냐 그리고 어
그것에 대해서 우리가 그럼 어떻게
생각을 해야 되느냐라는 관점에서
우영군 위원님은 어 좀 빚돼서 표현해
주셨는데 견제구는 어 승부구 그니까
스트라이크가 될 수 없다. 그래서 어
중국에서 수급을 한다 하더라도 아마
저가 기준으로 하게 될 거고 중국의
창신 메모리 등 반도체 업체들이 중국
내수도 커버하기가 좀 힘든 상황이라
또 더더욱 미국 빅테크에게 어 자기네
그 생산량을 의미 있게 줄 가능성도
좀 낮아 보인다고 해서 어 크게
휘둘릴 필요 없다라는 결론을 내려
주신 걸로 저는 첫 페이지 헤드라인만
보고 이해를 했어요. 그래서 어 그럴
수 있겠다. 정확히 저희보다 훨씬 더
지식이 높으시니까 잘 판단해 주셨겠다
싶으면서도 주식 시장은 또 심리나
미분값이 중요하다 보니까 저희가
요거를 어떻게 판단해야 되나 좀
여쭤보고 싶었습니다.
>> 질문이 많이 담겨 있는데요.
>> 네.
일단은 견제구로 활용을 하려는 거
같아요. 빅테크들이 CXMT나
YMTC 같은랜드
중국 업체들을 하는 거 같고 물론
이제 AI 서버에는 미국 향으로
들어가기 정말 힘들겠죠. 보안 이슈가
있기 때문에 힘들 거 같은데 뭐
애플도 지금 계속 요청을 하고
있잖아요. 6MT 수입을 승인해 달라
미국 정보한테. 그래서 어쩌면 지금
메모리가 정말
애플에서 평가 인상은 2, 30% 할
정도로 지금 부담이 되는 상황에서 음
>> 일부 소비자 제품들에 한해서는
어 허용해 줄지 말지에 대해서는 계속
감독을 열박을 할 것 같아요. 정부에
대해서. 그래서 거는 약간 옵션으로
놓으면 될 거 같고.
>> 어
>> 그리고 두 번째가 그
CXM 뭐였죠? 하면 세 가지 정도
됐었는데 어 그래서 그렇게 견제으로
활용을 해서음
좀 주도력을 어 수요자가 가져가려고
하는 거 같다. 그런데 요게
결과적으로는 의미 있는 수입이
미국으로부터 미국으로 추출을 중국이
못 하더라도
>> 그런 심리나 미분값의 변화가 있는 건
아닐까? 그래서 그 중국 내 지금
수요 충족하기도 지금 빠듯한 상황으로
알고 있어요. YMTC나 CMTX나
마찬가지로 MT나 마찬가지로
근데 [콧방귀] 이런 측해도 생각해
볼 수 있어요. 추후에 이제 물량이
확대가 될 거잖아요. 중국 내에서
확대고 나서 결국에는 어쨌든 수출을
하려고 할 텐데
>> 지금 현재 지금 따뜻한 상황에서 어
미리 레퍼런스를 좀 확보해 놓으려는
의신이 있을 것 같아요.음 음. 없는
없지만 조금
>> 없지만 발을 좀 걸쳐 놓으면 나중에
후출하기 편하니까
>> 승인을 받아 놓으면 미리 조금이라도
해서
>> 그런 쪽 니즈는
제가 중국 매물이 없나면 있을 것
같습니다. 미리
지금 아니면 다중 갈치기 힘들 거
있을 거 같다는 생각이 들고
전반적으로
중국 업체들한테는
뭐 기회 요인이면 우리한테는 약간
위기 요인일 수 있는데
>> 어쨌든 근데 중요한 거는 그 아까
협상력 말씀하 하하 하하
하하셨잖아요. 견제구 협장력이라고도
할 수 있는데
>> 사실 그 우리나라 정부
주도 하에서 이제 하이닉스랑 삼성전자
및 여러 AI 데이터 센터 등등 할
거 없이 다 투자를 하는데 어쨌든
케파까지 늘어날 거란 말이에요.
2028년도부터
물량 전체 케파에 한 15에서 20%
정도는 늘어날 걸로 보고 있어요.
그럼이 물량이 늘어난 거에 대해서는
어 지금 젤러스 마켓에서 협상이 좀
줄어들 수 있을 것 같습니다.
왜냐면은 바이어들이
>> 너네 이렇게 물량 늘어날 건데 단가
협상을 좀 해 줘야 되지 않냐 하면은
>> 지금까지는 쫄티지였기 때문에 우리
보터 준다 없다. 음
>> 다른데 알아봐라 할 수 있는데
>> 앞으로는 그러긴 조금 더 힘들어지지
않을까 싶습니다. 추가적인 물량이 어
공급 계약에 대상이 되는 거는 납품
기준으로 그럼 28년 9년 뭐 이럴
때 2023년도까지는 초티지 어 그
없고요. 그냥 사실상
>> 2028년도부터
>> 한 15% 정도 전체파의 물량이
날까요? 갈 것 같아요.
>> 한 K로만 300k에서 400K 정도
나올 것 같아요.
>> 음.네
>> 개 회사에서 합쳐가
>> 네네. 그러면은 전체 물량의 15에서
10% 정도 지금 현재 2,000k
정도 올해 말 기준으로 돼 있어서
340k면 15에서 20%면 적대하는
물량
>> 없는 것보다 훨씬 많죠. 협상의
도구로 쓸 수 있을 것 같습니다.
좀 전에 말씀드린 그 대신지권 리포트
보면서 또 어떤 파생적 생각을 했냐면
어쨌든 만약에 미국에서 어 반도체를
중국으로부터 수입하는 거를 정부가 좀
용인해 준다면 상대적으로 저가나 뭐
보안 이슈가 없는 것들 위주로 이렇게
해 줄 가능성이 높은데 그렇게 되면
어 역으로 생각해 보면 삼성전자나
하이닉스의 비즈니스 모델상 현재이
보안 고가 이런 비중을 보면
하이닉스가 비중이 월등이 좀 높아서
>> 그러면 상대적 적으로 삼성전자와
하이닉스의 호브로가 좀 생길 수도
있나 그런 생각도 좀 해봤습니다.이
>> 서버 비중이 높은 업체들이 아무래도
방어력이 좀 더 높다고 할 것 같고
ACBM 비중이 높은 업체들이 더 높
방어 받을 거고요. 왜냐면은 AI에
꼭 탑재되라는
>> GPU 연관 매물이기 때문에
그렇습니다.
>> 예. 그래서 삼성전자가 만약에
하이닉스보다 밸류에이션이 뒤쳐지지
않으려면 빨리 그런 고부가 제품 보안
이슈가 있는 제품 쪽에 매출 비중이
>> 어 확 늘어나야 되겠다 그런 생각도
좀 해 보게 됐습니다. 그죠?
알겠습니다. 제가 혹시 오과장님이 그
리포트를 밑에서 설명해 주시려나 하고
미리 좀 봤는데 요게 오늘 아침에
나왔나 그런가 봐요. 오장님이 볼
시간이 아직 없었나 봅니다.
>> 준비해 주신 두 개 리포트
보겠습니다. 첫 번째는 반도체
소재부품 한투 황준태 위원님 자료인
거 같습니다.
>> 네. 시간이 좀 많이 지나서 좀
보겠습니다. 소재 기업 쪽을 좀
주목해서 봐야 된다라는 이야기
있고요. 최근에 그 이란과 미국 간의
전쟁 때문에 중동 불확실성이 좀
있었잖아요. 그래서 원재료들이 좀
많이 상승했었다고 해요. 과산화
수소나
>> 수불산 신너 이런 제품들이 어 가격이
오르면서 소재 쪽이나 부품 쪽단에서
수익성화 우려가 좀 있었다고 합니다.
어 그래서 뭐 한 케미칼의 경우에는
과선화 수소 판가 인상을 최근에
진행을 했었다라고 하고 음
>> ENF 테크놀로지의 경우 판 협의를
진행 중인 상황이라고 합니다. 그래서
반도체 소재 업체들의 영업인 2분기를
바닥으로 좀 외이 개선되지 않을까라는
이야기를 했고요. 또한 소재 업체들의
12 포워드 멀티플이 밴드 중화단에
위치하면서 매력적인 밸루에이션 구간에
좀 진입한게 아니냐는 의견을 제시했고
그동안 소회되었던 한솔 케미칼 뭐
ENF 테크놀로지 솔브레인과 같은
소재 기업에 좀 우리가 다시 주목을
해 보자
소부장 중에서도
부품이나 장비수들은 그래도 좀
괜찮았었잖아요.
소재 쪽은 좀 관심에서 많이 멀어져
있었고
>> 밸류에이션도 좀 낮게 거래되고 있는데
이런 시점에 좀 보면 좋겠다라는
의견을 제시한 거 같고요. 밸루에이션
전고점을 넘기 위해서는이라고
하는데요. 장비주의 경우 12골포드
멀티플이 역사적 고점을 넘으는 후
26년 이후 새로운 밸루에이션 고점을
현재 형성하고 있다고 합니다.
>> 음. 이와 달리 소재주의 밸류는 아직
과거 역사적 고점에도 도달하지
못했다라고 하고요. 어 국내 전공정
소재 업체들의 랜드 익스포가 크기
때문일 것이라고 하는데 지금 뭐
삼성이나 하이닉스가 랜드 투자보다는
디램이나 HBM 쪽으로의 투자를
지속해서 늘리고 있잖아요. 그래서
랜드 쪽에 대한 투자가 적기 때문에
올해 소 올리 우리의 소재나 부품
쪽이 상대적으로 좀 부진할 수밖에
없었다. 이런 이야기를 했고요. 어
하지만 뭐 삼성전자가
P5의 랜드를 신규 증서할 것으로
현재 발표가 나고 있고 가동 시점이
28년 정도 된다라고 합니다. 그래서
소재 기업들의 경우의 본격적인 실적
성장은 한 28년 정도에 나타날
것이다라는 이야기를 했고요. 어 다만
이미 성장의 방향성은 정해졌기 때문에
장비주와 벌어진 밸류 차이를 그래도
좀 좁혀 나갈 수 있지 않을까
제시했습니다. 어 찾아보면 더 보이는
기회라고 해서 랜드 고단 쪽을
이야기를 했는데요. 랜드 신규 증설이
단기간 내에 요원하지만 랜드 고단화에
따른 웨이퍼당 소재 소문량이 크게
증가하는 기업의 경우에는 실적 성장이
좀 가파르게 나타날 수도 있겠다. 어
TCK와 3 AC캠이 좀 대표적이라고
하고요. TCK의 26년 매출
성장률은 YY 32 이익 증가율은
54.6% % 나타날 것으로 추정을
했습니다. NCK도 비슷한 흐름으로
나올 것으로 보고 있고요. 작년부터
ESSD 수요가 증가하면서 랜드
가격이 가파르게 증가를 했는데 신규
투자 증설 아 증설 투자는 쉽지
않을지라도 렌즈 재소들은 ESSD
대응을 위한 테크 마이그레이션만큼은
진행해야 된다라고 합니다.이 과정에서
높은 단수의 랜드캡화 비중이 어
상대적으로 좀 늘어날 수밖에 없다라고
하고요. 26년에는 비트 기준으로는
V8, V9에 해당하는 랜드가
50%를 넘어설 전망이기 때문에 랜드
고등화가 진행 중이다. 그래서 실제로
하이닉스와 전자는 올해 V9 전환
투자를 진행을 했다라고 하고요.
TCK는 SIC 리을 주력으로
공급하는 시각 소무품 제조 업체이기
때문에 글로벌 장비사가 주요 고객사
비4 마켓 플레이어라고 합니다. 랜드
고단화에 따른 수가 기대되는
TCK나캠
이런 종목들도 좀 관심 있게 우리가
보자라는 얘기를 제시했고요.
표는 앞서 말씀드린 대로 그 지금
웨이퍼 투입량은 계속 증가하고 있는데
랜드 웨이퍼 투입량은 감소하고 있다는
거죠. 웨이퍼 자체가 어디로 가냐?
D램 쪽이나 H램 쪽으로 상대적으로
많이 가고 있다라고 하는데
>> 그 웨이퍼트입량이
주가하고 있지 아 그 랜드 쪽으로론
증가하고 있지 않지만 3D 랜드
그러니까 5층으로 쌓는 랜드의 경우는
그 감소세가 줄어들고 있다고
하더라고요.
>> 그게 다 ESSD 때문이
>> 일반 랜드는 줄어들지 몰라도이 보다나
랜드 쪽은 그래도 선별적인 투자를
하고 있다
>> 볼 수가 있겠고요. 아래 보시면
솔브레인이나 한솔 케미칼의 피
배수인데요. 장비주들이랑 좀 다르죠.
장비주는
예를 들어 한소 케미칼로 예를 들어
보면 27배 21년도에 고점을
찍었잖아요. IT가 폭발적으로 나왔을
때.
>> 근데 지금 여전히 한 16배의 수준에
거래가 되고 있다라는 거죠. 그렇기
때문에 이런 부분이 앞으로 가면서
해소될 가능성이 좀 있다는 이야기를
해 준 거 같고요.
어 아래표로 내려가서 보면 제가
장비주 밸류랑 소재부 파란색이
TCK고요. 그리고 하얀색이 한소
케미칼 빨간색이 리노우 공업입니다.
TCK도 보면은 한 번은 이전 고점
피수를 뛰어넘고 내려온 상황이에요.
>> 음. 그리고 어 하얀색 한솔 케미칼은
뭐 그냥 박스 느낌에서 여전히 저런
수준에 있고 그리고 리노공업의
경우는 빨간색인데 리노공업도 한번
상반기 때 주가가 많이 올라가면서
밸루에이션 확장이 나타났었는데 이때
이제 34배 뭐 35배까지 취소면서
>> 어 리노은 그래도 이전 고점 비에서
한번 뛰어 넘었었습니다. 그래서
여기도 이제 소재단에도 보면 저는 뭐
한솔 케미칼이나
어 솔브레인 같은 싼 종목들도 있지만
여기 장기 밸류 테이블을 보면 결국에
반도체 사이클이 좋거나 실적 성장기가
오면 그 해당 산업에서 1등 애들이
가장 좋거든. 리노고 소켓 글로벌
1등, TCK, SIC 글로벌 1등
이런 소재 부품 쪽이 더 좀 더 좋아
보이고 뭐 솔브레인이나 한솔케미카
이런 기업들도 물론 메리트가 있지만
결국에 다 투자하기 힘들다면이
뭐 리노나 TCK의 밸류가 좀 더
높지만 이런 기업들 선택하는게 좀 더
>> 좋지 않을까? 그리고이 물릴 거라면
이런 기업에 물리는게 낫죠. [웃음]
한솔 케미칼 소브레 물리면 큰납니다.
언제 돌아올지 모르기 때문에.
>> 그래서 [웃음]
트레이딩을 잘하면 물론 좋긴 하겠지만
이제 제가 이제 개인적으로 트레이딩을
잘 못 하는 스타일이라서
>> 좀 더 이런 쪽으로 시선이 가는 거
같습니다.
>> 음.
[웃음]
>> 네. 물려도 좀 덜 아프기 덜 아픈
종목들이 있나 봐요.
>> 아, 좀 더 반등이
강하죠.
>> 음네. 물려도 참을 만하다. 아
참겠다는 마음이 드는 종목과
>> 물렸는데 아 어떡하지는 종목이 있고
그건 분명히 있는 거 같습니다. 저
예를 들어 뭐 이렇게 생각해 보면
되죠. 리노을 샀어요. 한 5%
빠져요. 어 그래 뭐 그래 이렇게
되고 [웃음]
뭐 한 한 달 지나니까 마이스 30%
돼 있네. 어 [콧방귀] 그래 좀 더
사지 이게 되는데
>> 예를 들어 솔브레인 어 샀다
>> 사자마자 5% 불리잖아
>> 아 자를까이 생각부터
>> 그런 느낌
>> 그런 관점에서 우리 오과장에게 삼성
SDI를 합니다.
나쁜 녀석 [웃음]
>> 5% 빠지면 잘라야 되나 이렇게
>> 아 5% 빠지면 어 비중학대 좀
기회다 좀 있는데 이제 한 20%
빠지면 또 나는 이렇게 [웃음]
>> 잠시 응답을 해 봤습니다. 큰틀에서
지금 이제 장비주보다는 소재 부품 쪽
밸루에이션이 어 그 주가에 이제
상대적으로 소재 부품이 더 안
좋았다. 그런 차원으로 말씀해 주신
거 같은데
>> 약간 눈을 좀 흐릿하게 풀고 여기
블룸버그 차트 두 개를 보면
>> 왼쪽 차트와 오른쪽 차트를 그냥
이렇게 겹쳐 놓은다고 봤을 때 어
[콧방귀] 크게 다른가 이런 생각도
전 좀 해 봤거든요. 그래서음
소재랑 장비 그 소재 부품과 장비가
원래도 밸루에이션이 좀 항상 이렇게
어떤 그 사업 모델 특성상 있었던
거지
>> 이게 원래 밸류에이션 레벨이 항상
같진 않았지 않았나
>> 아네 맞습니다.
>> 그래서 지금 소재 부품을 추천하는게
어 장비주보다
언더퍼폼 했기 때문이라고
보는게 맞는 건가 하는 생각도 좀
들고 예
>> 생각이 좀 복잡하네요. 어떻게 결론을
내려야 될지 모르겠어서
보면은 저도 이제 장비들
>> 관심이 있는데 미국 장비들 이제
대표적으로 ASML이나 어플라이드
머티리 리치나 이렇게 보면은
>> 지금 밸루에이션으로 보면은
>> 음
>> 그 역사적 고점입니다.
>> 예 역사적 고점 막 40배 50배 막
이러거든요. 그런데 아까 이제 그이
뭐 물론 네러티브긴 하겠지만
2030년까지 삼성
2080년까지인가요? 삼성이 2조면은
1년에 한 150조 정도 되거든요.
>> 근데 지금 시장에서 형성된 컨센은 한
1년에 한 80조에서 100조
정도예요. 그러면 이제 한 그 한
최소한 50% 이상 어 매년 애널리
그 성장을 한다면 그 돈이 결국에는
장비주 상당히 흘러갈 가능성이
>> 음
>> 있다고 생각이 되거든요. 그렇다면은
지금 밸루에이션 자체로이
밸류에이션을 멀티플을 어 비싸다고
봐야 될 것인지 아니면 시계를 뭐
2030년 또는이 그 이후로 봤을
때이 밸루에이션이 어 정당화 또는
합류화될 가능성이 높다고 봐야 될
것인지 그건 좀 고민이 되더라고요.
>> 음. 일단 비싼 건 맞는데
>> 어 상당히 확실해 보이는 저 번 미래
거를 좀 당겨와 봤을 때는 또
>> 비싸다고 그냥 완전 매도하기엔 또
그렇고
>> 그런 애매한 부분이 좀
>> 예 그 그런데 그
>> 애널리스트를 보고서 보면은 이번에
장비 사이클은
>> 좀 더 강하고
>> 음
>> 길 가능성이 있다라는 것이 대체적인
컨센서스거든요. 그래서 과거의 잣대로
봐서 이게 장비조를 평가해서 지금
비싸다고 해서 이거를 좀
도해시하기에는 조금 아쉬운 거
같습니다.
>> 네.
>> 우리 어장님도 비슷한 결의
생각이십니까? 아니면 조금 요런 것도
봐야 된다라는 말씀이 좀 있으실까요?
저도 비슷한 생각이죠. 그 부상님
말씀해 주신 이전과 다르다. 그게
>> 결국에는 B2C는 저희가 1년 반
정도 경기 사이클에 따라 반도체 수에
올라가면서 올라갔다가 또 1년 쉬다가
1년 반 올라가고 이런 느낌이었는데
>> 이건 B투비기 때문에 1, 2년이
아니라 뭐 3년, 길는 5년 이렇게
사이클이 길어질 수 있다. 그렇기
때문에 더 높은 밸류로 거래되는 건
정당하지 않아. 음.
>> 저도 거기에 통일을 하는
>> 알겠습니다. 제가 오늘 말씀을 너무
많이 드려서 시간이 좀 늦어지고
있는데 빨리 마지막 리포트 하나 더
보겠습니다. APR 한투 김명주
위원님 자료인 거 같습니다. 네.
리포트 내용 크게 많지 않았고 짧은
내용이었고 2분기 실적
전망이었습니다. 그래서 변한 건
없는데 주가만 좀 빠졌다라고 해서
한투 김명주 연구원님 자료였고요.
일단 2분기 실적에 대한 이야기를
했는데 매출 6,800억 영업 이익
1700억 전망하면서 뭐 APR은 뭐
Y 맨날 100% 이상입니다.
>> 그래서 매출도 100% 뭐 이익도
100% 증가 전망이고요. 오피마진도
한 25% 추정이 되고 있는데 뭐이
기준으로 시장 기대치 정도 나오지
>> 않을까라는 이야기를 했습니다. 뭐
시장 예상보다 미국이나 유럽 매출이
양호한 흐름을
>> 보였다라고 하고요. 일본계와
마찬가지로 국내나 일본 쪽은 좀
아쉬운 수준으로 나올 것으로 보고
있지만 미국과 유럽이 상당히 좋다라고
하고 또
4월에 타겟 쪽으로 1500개 이상
전포로 좀 들어갈 들어갔었다라고
하고요. 6월에는 월마트
3,000개의 점 입점 완료했고
3분기에는 코스트코 입점 성과까지
가셔야 될 가능성이 높기 때문에
1분기와 마찬가지로 2분기에도
공격적인 마케팅을 진행했었다라고
봅니다. 그래서 광고 선전 비율이 한
1.9% 포인트 YY로 늘어났을
거라고 추정을 했고요. 어 아마존
프라임데이에서 양 성과가 계속
나타나고 있고 JPR의 그 제품들이
아마존 프라임데이 그 화장품 순위의
상위권에 많이 랭크가 되는 거 기사로
많이 봤거든요. 그 부분 이야기를 해
준 거 같고 실적도 양호하고 산업도
양호한데 수급만 좀 아쉽다라고
합니다. 타겟 프라이스는 조정하진
않았고요. 52만 원 제시했는데 어
12월 포워드 비준 37배입니다.
꽤나 높은 밸류를 요하고 있고요.
AP 실적은 변함없이 양호하고 화장품
산업 또한 양호해 보인다라고 합니다.
최근에 일본이나 국내 쪽이 좀
부진하긴 한데이를 미국과 유로 화전
수출이 충분히 좀 상세해 주고
있다라고 하고요. 다만 올해 들어
주도 섹터로의 수급 솔림이 발생하면서
AP 또한 주가 고점 대비 약 16%
하락을 했다라고 봅니다. 시장
방향성을 예측하기는 어렵지만
주도주로의 수급 솔림이 좀 후금이라도
완화가 된다면 밸류 메리트는 있을거다
전망을 했습니다. 두 가지만 짧게
여쭤보고 지나가겠습니다. 허장품
섹터에 만약에 다시 온기가 좀 오고
매기가 온다면 저희가 전통적으로
봐왔던 아모의 LG 생활가 이런
종목들과 이렇게 AP처럼 새로운 사업
모델을 가지고 좀 가볍게 고정자산
유형 자산 없이 가는 회사들이
있는데음
양자간에 어느 쪽을 선택하는게 맞는
건지가 첫 번째 질문. 두 번째
질문은 어 회사는 변한 건 없고
밸루에이션만 빠졌다고 이제 김영주
위원님 말씀해 주셨는데 그 부분에
동의가 되시는지 아홉 번째 질문
>> 첫 번째 질문을 말씀드리면
전 아모래나 LG 생거는 왜 안
건드는게 맞다라고
단기적으로 한 번씩 어제처럼 급등할
때 있는데
>> 음
>> 그걸 추세로 보여 주면서 움직인 적이
한 번도 없어요. 왜냐면 실적이
우상향하는 모습을 지금
>> 음
>> 거의 3년 4년 동안 보여 준 적이
없기 때문에 3번 분기 실적 조금 잘
나왔다고 들어가면 다음 분기 때 또
바로 쇼크
>> 그래서 아 적어도 한 두 세 분기
정도 이익 추세가 유지되는 걸 보여
줘야네 그런 쪽으로 전통적으로 좀 갈
텐데
>> 지금 AP이나 파마리서치 이런
기업들의 화장품 수출 데이터가 굉장히
양호하고 좋거든요. 그중에서도 특히
APR이 좋은 상황이 저는 선택
화장품에서는
그 굳이 다른 거 봐야 되나? 그냥
음
>> AP 하나.
>> 음피 미용 기기는
>> 선별적으로 좀 이것저것 좋은 것들이
있기 때문에 거긴 고르기가 좀
어렵지만 화장품은 좀 정해져 있는
AP
>> 말고 굳이
>> 네. 그 ODM은 코스맥스보단 또
코스메카 코리아가 좀 나고 코스메카가
분기 실적이 계속 괜찮아요.
>> 코스맥스 한번 쇼크도 나 그런는데
>> 그래서 중 오히려 대형 ODM보다
중생 ODM 쪽이 좀 더 메리트가
있는고
생각이
>> 조금 들었고요.
>> 두 번째 질문으로 주신게 이제
밸류에이션인데
>> 네. 제가 요거 약간 질문의 취지를
좀 말씀드리면 뭐 예컨데 어떤 기업이
밸루에이션이 50배였다가 한 35배가
됐어요. 그러니까 어 밸루에이션이
너무 떨어졌다라고 얘기하는 거는 어
과거 대비 떨어졌다는 건지 이게 사업
모델이 바뀐 건지 원래 50배라는게
지나친 고평가였는지에 대한 판단이
없을 수도 있다라는 생각에 지금이
APR의 밸루에이션이 어 낮다라고
얘기할 수 있는 건지 좀
궁금했습니다.
>> APR이 높게 갔을 때가 한 30배
초반 정도였던 거 같은데요. 지금
24배 정도 수준이고 30배 갔던게
그럼 언제냐라고 좀 되짚어 보면 올해
초까지였던 거 같아요.
>> 지난해 하반기 때 이제 가장 좋았었던
거 같고.
근데 저번에도 제가 APR에 대해
조금 사형식품과 비교해서 말씀드린
적이 있잖아. 사망식품도
뭐 실적 자체는 아직도 좋고 연평균나
20% 성장은 예상이 되긴 하는데
밸류의 확장이 나타나기 어렵다라고
생각했던 이유가
>> 수출 비중이 이미 너무나 커진
상황이라
>> 음
>> OPM 개선이 둔화되는 경향이
보인다. 그래서 밸류가 떨어졌다라고
말씀을 드렸는데 AP 말씀드릴 때도
[목을 가다듬음] 그래 이제 수출
비중이 뭐 80% 육박하기 때문에
여기서 밸류에이션 확장을 나타나기 어
이익 증가만큼의 주가 상승을 기대해야
될 거 같다라고 말씀을 드렸는데
>> 그러면 저희가 피 미용이나 화장품의
밸류를 알면은 설명하기 쉽잖아요.
이제 왕부장님이 말씀해줬던 걸 토대로
보면 피용은 한 25배에서 높게
받으면 30배를 받습니다. 화장품은
그 스킨케어의 기준으로 보면 한
20배에서 25배가 가능하다라고 볼
수가 있는데 그러면 APR은 딱
거기에 적정한게 딱 수배 정도는 거
중간값을 해보면
>> 물론 지금 화장품 매출배율이 높아졌기
때문에 어 좀 더 화장품적으로 기울긴
하지만 그래도 25배 정도 주면 딱
적정한 밸류다 볼 수가 있어서 한
24배 되거든요. 그래서 뭐 싸지도
비싸지도 않지만 APR이
>> 어 실적 서프를 좀 잘내는 기업 중에
하나죠. 그래서 예를 들어
>> 한 15%만 서프라이즈 내도 그럼
연간 실적이 15%씩 분기로 사용
조정이 될 가능성이 있죠.
밸루에이션이 15% 떨어질 거고
15%만큼의 업사이드가 생기
보는게 좋죠. 실적 성장을 어 시장의
기대치를 충분히 줄 수 있는 과거
실적 발표를 했었고 그 실적 발표
증분만큼은이 늘 기대할 수 있는
정도의 밸류에이션까진 떨어졌다. 네.
>> 그렇게 이해를 좀 해보고
넘어가겠습니다.
>> 네. 우리 오과장님 준비해 주신 자료
다 말씀해 주신 건가요?
>> 네, 이상입니다.
>> 네. 오늘 모닝브리프 이부 여기까지
하고요. 마지막으로 이제 지수 예측
하고 넘어가 보겠습니다.
자, 한국 미국부터 보는 거죠?
>> 그럼 아, 편하신 대로요? 네. 어,
그래도 원래 미국부터예.
>> 음. 그러면 우리 유리프로
>> 지수들이 지금 좀 빠지고 있긴
한데요.
>> 음. 필반은 그래도 좀 오르고는
있는데
>> 네. 일단 아침에 말씀드렸듯이 좀
상반기가 좀 마무리되고 있는
시점이라서
>> 변동성 일단 심하다라는 전제를 먼저
깔고
>> 오늘은 그래도
어 상승하기 바라는 마음에서 SP랑
나스닥 둘 다 상승으로 하겠습니다.
>> 네. 길바는 상승이죠? 예,
상승입니다. 예, 상승이고요.
[웃음]
아, 뭐 오늘 그 단기 마지막 날인데
뭐 오늘 좀 매를 맞을 순 있습니다.
매를 맞을 수 있는데 어, 강세
마인드로 가는게 맞다고 생각을 하고
있고요.
>> 오늘 이제 막바지
>> 어, 변동성이 좀 나올 수는 있을 것
같은데
>> 어, 그 변동성을 피하기보다는 맞야
된다고 생각을 하고 있고요. 예.
그리고 어 조도 섹터의
회기 시점이 멀지 않았다고 생각을
합니다. 그래서
>> 네
>> 기존에 나타났던 약간 소외 주술의
반등
>> 음
>> 그리고 주도 섹터의 조정
이런 부분은 오래 가지 못할 거라고
생각합니다.
>> 네네
지금 유튜브 댓글에서 우리 채미턴
분들이
>> 우리 최부 사장님은 최선비다.
>> 왜요? 어, 우리 최부사장님은
최배달이다. 지금 어, 굉장히
캐릭터가 다른 두 개의 닉네임이
나왔는데 오늘은 이제 최배달 모드로
>> 아, [웃음] 그러네.
>> 맞서 싸워라 이렇게 말씀을 해주.
>> 아, 항상 이제 바이어스가 있는
거죠. 자기 포지션이 있으니까. 근데
제가 볼 때는 이제 이런 구간에서
사실은 굉장한 고민을 할 수밖에
없거든요. 그러니까 지금까지 좀 잘
가다가
>> 음. 어 그 좀 흔들리게 되면은
포트나 시장이 내가 생각했던 거하고
좀 어 다르게 가게 되면 되면은 뭔가
좀 그 방향성이
바뀌고 있나? 시장의 스타일이 바뀌고
있나?
가격만 보면은 그렇게 될 수 있는데
그 기저의 어떤 요인들을 다시 한번
꼼꼼히 살펴보면은
>> 좀 흔들릴 이유는 없다고 생각을 하고
있고요. 행태 신략적으로 보면은 예를
들어서 어 100% 수익을 냈다가
5% 손실이 나서 95%
에의 수익이
>> 음
>> 어 그 평가되는 거하고 50% 수익이
났다가 5%가
수익이 나서 올라서 55%하고 같은
5%지만
>> 그 감정의 크기 박탈감의 크기
그러니까 전자에서 이제 5% 손실이
나서 95% 된 거에 박탈감의
크게하고
>> 어 50% 수익에서 5% 더 올라서
55%나는 기쁨의 크기하고 음
>> 전자가 훨씬 크거든요. 그래서 예,
전자가 훨씬 큽니다. 왜냐하면 어
생태심리학이 이제 레퍼런스 포인트라고
나오는데 기준점이 항상 그 고점이
되고 어 마음속에 원금이 항상 고점이
되기 때문에 그 원금에서 어 손신하는
것이 아주 많은 무적 수익이 났다고
하더라도 어 그 마음속에 원금 자체가
항상 고점이기 때문에 상실감이 되게
크거든요. 음.
>> 어, 그런 상실감을 느낄 만한
구간이라고 생각을 하고 있고
>> 상방인까지 잘 주도들을 갖고 오셨던
분들도 마음이 흔들리는 구간이 있을
수가 있습니다. 실제로 그런 어,
상담도 받고 있고요.
>> 어, 그런 것들을 좀 견뎌내서 좀이
관을 잘 좀 극보했으면 하는 그런
바람입니다.
>> 아, 예. 저희 마음까지 회아를
주시는 우리 사수님. [웃음] 네.
앉겨라. 변곡점은 내가 알려주겠다.
>> 아니, 근데 정말로 말씀하신 그 5%
플러스 마이너스는 우리가 늘 누구나
느끼는 그런 감정이기 때문에 그럴 때
조금 더 시계를 멀리 보고 방향성이
달라진 건지 평가해 보면 마음이
편안해질 수 있습니다. 그런 말씀해
주신 거 같습니다.
>> 자, 한국 시장 예측해 보겠습니다.
코스피 코스닥 오늘 됩니까?
잠시
일단 우리 오과장이 가장 최근에 많이
해 주었던 그 볼린저 밴드 상단을
타고 올라간다는 거는 요정을 받으면서
지금 레퍼런스로 삼을 수 없게
됐어요. 네.
음.
오늘은 양복날 가능성이죠. 음. 다
>> 보이고요. 일단 시장 조정은이 정도로
>> 끝났다라고 생각.
>> 음.
>> 여기서 [목을 가다듬음] 이제 박스로
갈지 아니면
>> 음.
>> 또 9,000 포인트 넘어가면서
볼린저 상단을 뚫고 또 시도를 할지는
모르겠지만
>> 네.
>> 오늘은 내용 반도체가 어 한 이틀간
납폭이 워낙 컸기 때문에
>> 기술적 반등이라도 나올 자리라고 하서
>> 상승으로
>> 음. 좀 전에 잠깐만요 하고 우리
오가장 화면에서 삼성전자 하이닉스
요렇게 반등 나오나 봤어요? 아니
차트 봤습니다. 차트 봤어요? 주가를
보면
>> 지수 차트네
알겠습니다. [웃음]
무엇을 보고 판단했는지 좀 알려
주세요. 우리도 좀 배우지.
우리 왕부장처럼
봉입니다. 얀봉입니다 하고 이
>> 모델에 의하면 모델 안 가리켜주실
종목을 보니까 좀 아 전자가 [웃음]
골린저 중단을 뚫고 내려와 있거든요.
네. 나갔다. 걸린데.
>> 그러면 사실 중단 깨고 내려가면
>> 음.
>> 하단을 한번 다녀오는 경우들도 왕이
있어서
>> 음.
>> 그렇게 치면은 한 28만 원까지
빠져야 되고.
>> 음. 뭐
>> 그렇지 않자 싶습니다.
>> 그래서 첫 번째 어 양봉 의견 유지.
네.
>> 맞습니다.
>> 네. 코스닥은 어저께 음봉은 음봉인데
조금씩 좋아지고 있다. 그런 얘기해
주셨는데.
>> 오늘 데이터 좀 분위가
>> 어제보다 더 좋아졌어요.
>> 음.
안봉지. [웃음]
>> 네.
그때 근데 데이터존 분위가이 속도
유지하면
>> 좀 연봉도 전화할 수 있어요.
>> 오늘
>> 오늘은 마무리 잘 되면
>> 아 그러면 양봉해야지 왜 음봉
>> 아 그 음봉나요 결과 좀
>> 무슨 데이터 본 건지 좀 힌트 좀
줘요.
>> 어 여러 가지 데이터 좀 있지요.
>> 어 그 여러 가지가 뭔지 좀
알려줘요.
>> 아 뭐 우리 알고 있는 거 다
있습니다.네 [웃음]
네. 네. 추세저대표도 있고 아
지표도 있고
>> 다만 가충치 있는 가종치를 계속
변동.
>> 아, 변동해서 맞아요. 이게 그래서
TV에도 보면 생활의 달인이나 이런
데서 레피 다이 명인들이 알려 주셔도
어, 넣는 비중, 속도, 간격 뭐
이런게 다 달라서 알려줘도 못
합니다. 물어봐도 의미가 없는데
그래도 궁금해서 좀 물어봤습니다.
>> 네. 자, 오늘 채슬리 모닝 브리프
2부 여기서 마치도록 하고요. 어,
궁금하신 점들 있으시면 댓글에 올려
주시면 저희가 또 오후에 엄신박이나
어, 신차 이런 것들 통해서 또
말씀을 드리도록 하겠습니다. 오늘
2부까지 긴 시간 함께 해 주신
채미턴 여러분들 감사드립니다. 내일
뵙겠습니다. 감사합니다.